a terrified man huddles in the corner
heart pounding in teeth chattering he
sees them coming towards him huge
eight-legged figures Ten Feet Tall at
least with eight black soulless eyes
that seemed to stare hungrily at him
it's like something out of a nightmare
giant man-eating spiders everywhere they
approached the man fangs dripping with
Venom but just as they're about to
strike he vanishes he won't be spider
food today but for this truly unlucky
guy his ordeal is far from over let's
rewind when life gets a little too
boring we all daydream about getting
away maybe you imagine sitting on a
tropical beach or camping in the
mountains and breathing in the fresh air
some of the more adventurous types with
a vivid imagination might daydream about
visiting a parallel universe who
wouldn't want the chance to see what
life is like in another dimension of
course it would only be fun to go go
there if you could control where you
went and when you could come back
without any control over it the ability
to hop back and forth between Dimensions
would turn from a blessing to a curse
just ask
scp-507
scp-507 unlike most other scps is a
seemingly normal human man he has blonde
hair green eyes and unrecognizable
accent and no other features that might
make him stand out he looks perfectly
average Like a Stranger you'd pass on
the street and never give a second
thought to what sets him apart is not a
physical attribute but rather an ability
that he has yet to develop a firm grasp
on he is a dimension Hopper with no
control over where he goes or when he'll
get back after appearing on the grounds
of a mental treatment facility with no
identification rambling about a world of
giant spiders
scp-507 was admin to the hospital and
sedated for his own safety he would
spend several months in treatment for a
variety of supposed disorders but once
he became aware of his surroundings he
attempted to escape the hospital
multiple times during these Escape
attempts he often eluded Hospital staff
by mysteriously disappearing and
reappearing in seemingly impossible
places such as behind locked doors or in
rooms blocked off from the rest of the
hospital these disappearances and
reappearances seem to be contrary to
what the hospital staff first believed
Beyond his control the SCP Foundation
became aware of the strange phenomena
surrounding 507 and he was removed from
the hospital and brought to an SCP
Foundation facility once there the
nature of his abilities became much
clearer
scp-507 is able to without intent or
even knowledge that it is about to occur
shift from this reality to an another
alternate reality after some time there
with the amount of time varying from
case to case you will shift back to this
reality he has been known to shift
realities while sleeping in the middle
of a sentence and even while bathing or
going to the bathroom the shifts are
unpredictable and there is no telling
what kind of Horrors he will encounter
in the new dimension where he ends up
leading to 507 having seen some very
strange things even by a CP foundation's
standards during one of his shifts 507
found himself in a pitch black room
filled with the sound of muted breathing
using a flashlight he had been given by
the foundation he looked around and
found that he was not alone in the room
with him was a man wearing a black suit
and sunglasses with a frightening
inhumanly wide smile The Smiling man
leaned in towards 507 so close that
their faces nearly touched and said back
so soon terrified 507 fired several
rounds from a foundation-issued pistol
then curled up in the corner of the room
until he shifted back to our reality
this would not be the last time that he
encountered The Smiling man according to
document
507-3b which details all of 507 shifts
into other realities 507 was found in a
Midwestern cornfield by Foundation staff
with brown liquid on its cheek in his
hand he held a human heart with the
words I need you written on it in the
same brown liquid before he shifted back
and landed in the cornfield 507 shifted
to a pitch black room filled with the
sound of muffled crying he turned on his
flashlight taking note of his
surroundings and found himself face to
face with the smiling man once again The
Smiling man had brown liquid leaking
from around its sunglasses which it
wiped onto 507's cheek upon further
examination 507 saw several bullet holes
in The Smiling Man's suit leaking the
same brown liquid he attempted to fire
his pistol like he had the previous time
but it did not fire as The Smiling man
began to approach him 507 turned and ran
he ran for about 10 minutes before
finding a corner where he stayed huddled
once again until he shifted Back The
Smiling man is not the only nightmare
that scp-507 has encountered on his
travels
during another shift 507 described
appearing in a small room filled with
dried corpses a single window and a
flickering light hanging from a ceiling
while attempting to wait out his time in
the room he discovered that the corpses
were capable of movement whenever the
room was in darkness the corpses would
pose themselves like living people when
he looked out the window the corpses
would join him and look out the window
with him when he sat down they would sit
with him in the circle 507 attempted to
pass time by falling asleep but was
unable to do so though many of his
experiences were disturbing only one of
507's documented shifts resulted in him
requesting a memory wipe from the SCP
Foundation on this one he found himself
in the maternity wing of a large
Hospital a creature dressed like a nurse
approached 507 and told him that he was
upsetting the other patients and that it
was time to start the operation 507 was
then wrapped in the straitjacket and
wheeled into an operating room after the
straitjacket was taken off 507 grabbed a
chair and swung it wildly at the
creatures to keep them at Bay until he
shifted back when he asked to describe
the appearance of the nurse creature 507
began screaming in Terror and was unable
to provide a coherent description he
attempted to provide a drawing of the
creature but was only able to produce a
series of jagged lines following this
encounter his request for a memory wipe
was denied other shifts included going
to a world where every surface was
covered with an unidentifiable mold a
land of icy Tundras populated by
aggressive bears and one place that he
refused to describe Beyond repeating the
phrase so many spiders not all of the
worlds that 507 has encountered are
frightening some are simply strange and
unusual during one shift he found
himself on a large basketball court
where six other individuals were playing
a game game of basketball there were two
humans two insectoid creatures one
creature resembling a squid and one
hovering yellow sphere with eight arms
when 507 asked where he was he was
informed that he had arrived at the all
species Sports Center during another
shift 507 found himself in a world made
entirely of gelatin during yet another
shift he appeared in a large Auditorium
filled with 50 000 other dimension
Hoppers who were holding a political
Rally For The People's Dimension Hopper
Republic working with the Republic over
the course of two weeks 507 helped to
overthrow the United States government
and establish a new one run by Dimension
Hoppers
scp-507 was elected representative of
Massachusetts but just before he could
introduce his first official piece of
legislation he shifted back to our
reality one day at the facility a
particularly unusual event involving
scp-507 occurred the events of which
were documented in interview
507-g during a regular check-in it was
discovered that there were somehow two
identical versions of
scp-507 in its room they had apparently
each arrived in the room independently
and had been talking to one another for
about half an hour before being
discovered these two versions were
referred to as 507-a and
507-b when prompted for an explanation
507-b explained that there were more
than one version of scp-507 Afflicted
with uncontrollable Dimension hopping
the doctor inquired as to which one of
the two was the visitor but the two
declined to answer fearing that this
knowledge would cause the foundation to
view one of them as Expendable the two
had multiple shared experiences that
they related to the doctor including
both having encounters with the smiling
man during the interview
507-b disappeared mid-sentence and did
not reappear the doctor asked 0.07-a
about identifiable differences between
his and his Devil's realities
507-a explained that in 507-b's World
President Lincoln was killed by his vice
president whereas in 507-8's world he
was killed by General Lee this
Revelation made it clear that neither
507-a nor 507-b were native to this
reality after this was revealed 507-a
was terminated and examined no
biological reason for 507's ability to
hop from Dimension to Dimension was
found though it was discovered that
several pieces of 507 will shift
Dimensions along with the rest of the
body three days after this interview was
conducted the correct scp-507 reappeared
with no knowledge of his doppelgangers
or what became of them
scp-507 is classified as safe meaning he
doesn't require any real effort to
contain he's also safe in the more
literal sense in that he poses no threat
to anyone else the only person in danger
in the presence of scp-507 is himself as
he has been exposed to many dangerous
conditions during his reality shifts and
it's never known whether 507's next
shift will end up being his last with
the cause of his shift still being
unknown there is nothing that the
foundation can do to prevent them all
they can do is monitor him and provide
him with the items that might ensure his
safety in the future like a handgun
loaded with rubber bullets a tank of air
a high intensity flashlight a week of
ration packs a pair of binoculars a
tracking collar and a camera the
tracking collar allows the foundation to
recover 507 when he shifts back to our
reality in the location other than the
containment facility the rest of the
equipment was granted at his request
based on obstacles that he encountered
in other dimensions due to his docile
nature 507 is given freedom to move
about the facility but when he leaves
his private room an agent must go with
him to document any shifts that might
occur no one is allowed to touch
scp-507 though if it has been more than
two weeks since a shift occurred this
policy stems from an incident in which
an agent who is touching 507's shoulder
at the time of a shift was taken with
him and did not return when he is not
shifting
scp-507 lives a relatively normal life
at the facility he has allowed his own
computer with internet access and can
meet with other safe or euclid-class
scps that are not infectious or
detrimental to his health 507 has
expressed an interest in the unusual and
paranormal and has enjoyed meeting with
other scps including a request to visit
scp-082 for a vacation so far all of
these meetings have occurred without
incident due to his anomalous shifting
scp-507 will never be able to live a
normal life unless he stops shifting he
will likely spend the rest of his days
bouncing between unknown dimensions and
his containment facility just like so
much else about him his relationship to
his special talent is a bit of a paradox
he has the ability to go anywhere to see
things no other person on Earth has ever
seen however because he cannot control
it cannot stop it no matter how far away
he can travel he will never truly be
free over 50 men and women clad in red
robes kneel before an Unholy altar they
chant and mutter indecipherable words
words of Cruelty and Madness of
obsession and sacrilege not long ago
these were regular people computer
technicians teachers plumbers
construction workers accountants this
was before they fell under the Godly
influence of a new ruler the center of
this makeshift place of worship was once
a normal school gymnasium but it's now
the home of a huge statue a humanoid
being wreathed in tentacles its head is
more like a squid or cuttlefish than
anything resembling an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the Beast they worship is
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-2662 and he sits in the belly of one
of their expansive containment
facilities locked away from the world
but not for long if his devoted
followers have anything to say about it
this is their God all-powerful and
unchanging and when it comes to
springing him from containment no tactic
is too vile or underhanded to get the
job done their mortal leader and high
priest a man in a purple robe calling
himself brother Marsh walks among their
crouched forms he whispers instructions
for the great day of Liberation that's
soon to come providing everyone plays
their part it's a plan months in the
making and one that if it goes off
without a hitch could free their
monstrous God into the world they would
strike at the very heart of their enemy
the SCP Foundation when they least
expect it and nothing shall stand in
their way how could they lose when they
have a God on their side but why did all
these normal people become violent
zealots for a squid-faced deity it all
began with a dream to those who
experience these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
Glorious Horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon their
tentacled God hold holding Dominion
overall at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken in afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't every night the
nightmare would return they'd see the
images the Red Sky the dead and Enslaved
the tentacled God and after a while it
would come to them even when they
weren't asleep eventually happening
whenever they closed their eyes little
by little this scene stopped looking so
hideous and started to look glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe and to experience the
honor of serving him many of them
abandoned their homes and families
leaving their friends and loved ones
left to worry that they'd Gone Insane In
Their Eyes they were safer than they'd
ever been they finally had purpose they
were working in service of something far
greater than themselves the influence of
the tentacled god drew them closer to
one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
rulers sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
Idols to congregate around they
performed dark blood rituals involving
human and animal sacrifice it was when
brother Marsh the anointed one arrived
to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear just
three months prior brother Marsh had
been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded His
Thoughts with a simple message free me
and the new world I create shall be your
playground since then he devoted himself
completely to the cause quitting his job
and maxing out his credit cards to help
fund his new life's purpose infiltrating
the SCP Foundation and releasing his
inhuman ruler from its imprisonment that
was the single goal he United the
cultist under freedom for the tentacled
God and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary Intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on Earth even the strongest
institution is made of people and people
are weak unlike the almighty tentacled
God people could be broken the people in
question were Kelly Thompson Sydney
Levitt Jordan brosh Dr Juan Gutierrez
and Jillian Larson Dr Juan Gutierrez was
a researcher with level 3 clearance on
the site where the tentacled God was
being contained Sydney Levitt and Jordan
brosh were both security officers
charged with verifying Personnel
clearance on site Kelly Thompson was a
member of site Administration with
research authorization powers and
Jillian Larson was a research assistant
who often collaborated with Dr Gutierrez
these five were the key to getting
access to
scp-2662 and bringing their plan
to fruition normally Personnel dossiers
on people working for the foundation
were highly confidential but the
devotees of the tentacled God had their
ways they had a number of computer
experts in their ranks more than capable
of hacking in and pulling some basic
information off of foundation servers
without being detected for the other
information they needed they turned to
some good old-fashioned torture which is
often the most effective method when you
need some quick results of course while
the Colts grip on sanity may have been a
little tenuous they weren't stupid while
Gathering their Intel they also made
sure to find out what exactly they were
up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
Task Force Town nine better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping Mall Cops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these Foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother Marsh's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock Tau 9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 Cults and dismantling them and
brother Marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled God then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming Force the
scp-2662 worshipers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key Foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of Ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their God Dr Gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept Sydney Levitt and
Jordan brosh were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening Thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire Jillian Larson had
seen that mask Figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother Marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two-minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victims closets and were
handed the correct Forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their Journeys to the site where the
tentacled God was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
SCP Foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one slip
neatly into position disappearing into
the familiarity of office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled God
would be another thing entirely that's
where the rest of the cult would come
into play heavily armed with whatever
Firearms they could get their hands on
the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother Marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect they launched their
attack from the outside and from within
when brother Marsh declared that the
time was right the assault began a
legion of gun wielding cult is seemed to
Spring out of nowhere and started
shooting up the warehouse that was a
front for the containment site the site
quickly mobilized guards and task force
members to take on the sudden threat and
just as brother Marsh had anticipated
the site director called on the majority
of town nine to help repel the violent
cultists from their perimeter Town 9
obeyed leaving three task force members
behind a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their God what they didn't
expect was a group of five Foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two Town nine
members and taking the third as hostage
while the war was being waged outside
the infiltrators had found the tentacle
Gods containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid War their hostage insisted that
using him wouldn't give them any
leverage the rest of his team would
neutralize the whole group him included
if that's what it took to stop them the
infiltrators explained that using him as
leverage was never their intention he
wasn't a hostage at all he was a
sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662 twice as tall as a regular man
with 10 huge tentacles emerging from its
back in their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen still
God's work in mysterious ways so they
stuck to the plan and began chanting
they pulled out a sacrificial dagger and
began sacrificing their captured tau9
member it was at this point that
scp-2662 turned and saw what they were
doing with a look of pure horror he rose
up from his computer his headphones
getting caught as he did so he told them
to go away that he didn't want here and
that the murdering people in this
bedroom like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their God accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong they tried more chanting and
painting Arcane symbols on the floor and
blood but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian God to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place before the cultist
infiltrators could get another word in
the remaining members of town 9 stormed
into the containment cell and gunned
them down with surgical Precision the
war outside was already over brother
Marsh and the rest of the cultists were
all killed in the firefight Town 9
didn't look the least bit surprised upon
entering 2662's cell this was a common
occurrence Unfortunately they had to
deal with an attempted cult Invasion
every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent Cults who relentlessly
Tracked Down and Worship it with Arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the SCP Foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
Cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled God just one
of many Cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining Town nine
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the SCP Foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept down reality warpers real pieces of
work aren't they it's one thing when an
anomaly is all Claws and fangs like
scp-682 or if their attack of choice is
snapping necks like SCP-173 but it is an
entirely different story if an anomaly
can turn the air you breathe into
chocolate pudding or shove you into a
pocket Dimension that looks almost like
our own reality except everyone is just
a walking talking pile of spiders see
what I mean reality warpers real
handfuls though of course not all
reality warpers are created equal some
are relatively weak only affecting the
world around them in a mild ambient
fashion others can rattle whole
Dimensions with their tremendous power
the same also goes for Morality some
reality warpers are loving and
benevolent such as scp-343 the kindly
old all-powerful being known to some as
God and some are pure evil beings who
want nothing more than to use their
immense power to sow chaos and misery
among everyone else and personally we
can't think of a better example of the
latter than Bill Cipher from Gravity
Falls this demonic Dorito wants nothing
more than to take over our Dimension and
rebuild it in His image of absolute
Insanity so naturally we started
wondering if these two reality warping
Titans scp-343 and Bill Cipher ever came
to blows who would win we were so
curious in fact that we fired up the
animatron 6000 our state-of-the-art
simulation supercomputer to see how
exactly the two might meet and how their
epic battle would play out who do you
think would take the coveted W on this
one let us know down in the comments
along with any other out of universe
what-if situations you'd love to see but
in the meantime let's fire up the
machine be warned folks it's gonna get
weird the date was July 12 2013. for
scp-343 it had started out as a
relatively normal day he'd spent the
night playing Solitaire on the astral
plane before warping back into his
humanoid containment cell by morning
leaving the foundation on the wiser
after all he was really here voluntarily
if the foundation had truly wanted to
try to confine him here they were
welcome to give it a go but it would be
about as effective as trying to catch a
win whisper in a butterfly net while God
had come to this place to experience the
joyful illusion of giving up control it
truly was little more than an allusion
to him if he wanted to he could
exterminate the SCP Foundation in less
than an afternoon then retire to Burger
King for a Whopper so really they're all
just lucky he is a benevolent being more
interested in hanging out than
dispensing wrath on those he perceived
as insolent that was Old Testament him
he'd done a lot of soul-searching and
growth since then they'd been at least a
millennium since he'd smote anyone for
that matter and the last guy really had
it coming however today was going to be
a little different God knew that
something was going to happen today he
sensed a great source of energy emerging
something dark and malevolent he sighed
and he closed his eyes for a moment
focusing himself he knew whatever the
nature of this threat it would fall upon
him to face and destroy it how
irritating he was hoping to find only
been stranger things today elsewhere
inside 19 things seem to be inordinately
peaceful there hadn't been any
containment breaches or new anomalies
brought in there hadn't been any attacks
from rival groups of Interest Dr Wright
hadn't even done anything stupid or
started any fires to borrow an old
cliche it was quiet too quiet perhaps
the only person who wasn't having a
relatively mellow day was security
officer Frederick Simmons a mid-level
guard who'd been stationed at site 19
for four years now he just wasn't really
feeling himself today the work didn't
bother Simmons emotionally at least
typically even after seeing rather
traumatic things or being in near-death
situations while in containment breaches
it hadn't left any lingering effects but
lately he'd been having this strangest
streams it always played out the same
way shortly after going to sleep he'd
open his eyes in a strange multi-colored
void surrounded by bizarre seemingly
random floating objects none of which
seem to have any real relevance to him
or his life and just when he'd begin to
question it the other recurring element
of the dream would occur out of the
shimmering oil slick rainbow of
mind-boggling colors a strange being
would suddenly emerge a glowing Golden
Triangle almost like a drawing of a
pyramid the Eye of Providence with a
stove pipe hat a little bow tie thin
black arms and legs and most notable of
all a single large eye with a slit pupil
staring out from the center the eye
almost seemed to have a strange hypnotic
quality to it Simmons felt Bewitched
whenever he looked into it he wasn't
afraid quite the opposite actually for
reasons he couldn't understand this
strange creature from the world of
Dreams seemed like a good friend of his
he said well well well well well well if
it isn't my number one guy the Fred
Meister in the house I've missed you
have you miss me butter there good buddy
The Entity extended his hand and Simmons
shook it the foundation guard could feel
a strange tingling sensation jolting
down his arm the first time Simmons had
encountered The Entity he'd told him his
name Bill Cipher and he told him how
incredibly important it was that Simmons
kept their little nighttime meetings a
secret in Exchange bill was here to
listen Simmons would spend his time in
the mindscape pouring out his worries
and frustrations with his daily work as
bill paid impeccable attention the
strange Little Dream entities seemed
fascinated by the work Sim instead all
the peculiar and wondrous anomalies he
guarded at site 19. but to Simmons it
was all just boring work zombie creating
Supernatural plague doctors and Immortal
men with metal limbs lose their shine
after you see them day in day out for
years on end frankly Simmons needed a
day off but he'd already used up all his
PTO when he'd gotten the flu earlier
that year he just didn't know what to do
luckily for him Bill had a solution bill
as it turned out had a fancy little
ability he could occupy the body of a
human being and operate it for them bill
could take the wheel while Simmons took
a load off in the mindscape how hard
could standing around pretending to look
busy at the SCP Foundation really be as
Bill explained the offer to him Simmons
couldn't really see any flaws in his
reasoning after all bill was a friend
why would he have any ill will towards
him with that he shook hands with the
bizarre Supernatural triangle and felt
the sudden rough sensation of having his
Consciousness ripped from his body only
for Bill to Slither in and take his
place the new Simmons the bill occupied
Simmons opened up his demonic yellow
eyes and grinned he gave a demented
laugh to Simmons floated disembodied
Soul
oh man he said wiping away a tear of
after was Simmons finger with your body
I can use the SCP foundation's
technology to take over the Multiverse
see ya sucker and with one last demented
chuckle Bill left for work at the SCP
Foundation with Simmons being the latest
in his long line of Meat Puppets after
arriving at site 19 he sneaked through
the facility knowing exactly where he
needed to be you see Bill is a native
entity of the second dimension the world
of flat shapes but he's able to access
the minds of beings in the third
dimension like us through the medium of
the mindscape rather than the Physical
Realm Bill's life goal has always been
to find a way to permeate and take over
the third dimension turning it into his
personal playground all he needed was
the right anomaly to bring him forth
into our world in this case a little
anomalous device favored by Dr Kane
pathos Crow
scp-158 also known as the soul extractor
while Dr Crow Left To the courtyard for
his evening walkies the being that most
people assumed was Fred Simmons secreted
himself into scp-158's containment
chamber and locked the door behind him
he didn't have much time he'd need to do
this perfectly if he wanted a real
chance at taking over the universe he
was amused by the irony at the least the
fact that in order to take over he
needed to sneak into the midst of the
people most likely to destroy him still
where's the fun in life with no risk at
scp-158's control console he inputted
the data to Soul extraction and set a
timer however there was one difference
between this and the usual procedures
performed with the soul extractor there
was no containment receptacle on the
other end whatever was extracted would
just be released into the world and this
was exactly what bill was counting on he
laid Simmons body down on the gurney and
watched with Glee as the robotic arm
lowered towards him it reached into his
chest and pulled out the essence of one
three-sided threat to reality Bill
Cipher one quick Journey Through the
bowels of the machine later the
nightmare scenario had come to pass Bill
floated around the room dragged into
physical reality he let out a long
conceited cackle and spun his Cane
around this was going to be fun
elsewhere in the facility alarms were
going off and guards were deploying
nobody was meant to be in containment
chamber 158 so how was the soul
extractor currently operating this
couldn't possibly end well bill on the
other end was having a wonderful time it
was pondering all the different ways he
could make the draft clinical corridors
of the SCP Foundation into his vision of
perfect weirdness maybe he turned all
the researchers into mice and turned
site 19 into a giant maze to run them
through maybe he turned the air into
farts and release winged beasts from the
hell Dimension to ravage Humanity maybe
he'd go out into the parking lot and key
everyone's cars oh the Diabolical
possibilities were endless as he floated
out into the Hall his fantasizing was
interrupted by a group of foundation
security operatives wielding assault
rifles they entered an attack formation
and trained their rifles on him before
opening fire bill just found himself
laughing again the gunfire just tickled
wow you guys are hilarious Bill said
between fits of laughter but wait
he snapped his fingers and suddenly the
guards were transformed instead of the
serious first line of defense for the
SCP Foundation they were now a gang of
literal clowns straight from the circus
holding balloon animals molded into the
shapes of assault rifles they giggled
and threw pies at each other bill was
right this did make them even funnier
and he was just getting started turning
this Foundation snooze Fest into a party
of cosmic proportions Bill began running
a rampage of weirdness across the site
essentially being the ultimate Cosmic
troll he decided he'd simply bother
every single anomaly he could with his
demonic Antics first he appeared in
scp-096's chamber and pulled a brown
paper bag over his head with the words
ugliness lies within written on the
front and just for fun he then
teleported the temperamental Beast to a
nearby Amish community it quickly became
enraged when a gust of wind blew the bag
off its head and a man named Jebediah
saw its face it then killed several
others also named Jebediah during the
Rampage Bill thought it was hilarious he
then released scp-682 into site 19 and
just to annoy the creature into further
violence he stuck an indestructible
party hat on the monster's head no
matter how hard 682 tried it couldn't
remove the party hat this caused it
great frustration which it took out on
any foundation staff it happened to find
in the area it had fulfilled Bill's
expectations wonderfully but his quest
for amusing Carnage didn't end there
next he went to bother scp-049 the
plague doctor who was in the process of
doing surgery on a foundation-provided
dead goat with a snap of his fingers
Bill transformed the plague doctor's
surgical tools into colorful Play-Doh
cutting tools needless to say the
supernatural surgeon was less than
pleased he was about as annoyed as Dr
clef was when bill turned his favorite
shotgun into a bouquet of flowers then
sealed his feet into the floor or how
Vex Dr gears was when bill turned his
plain beige necktie into a considerably
more loud and colorful tie people there
at the time reported hearing Dr gear say
I just don't think that was necessary oh
and he also did some more minor acts of
malice he filled the break room with an
army of flesh-eating zombies he made a
mode filled with molten lava around the
site that prevented anyone from escaping
from his reign of terror and he even
covered all the walls in cognito
hazardous Doodles that instantly drove
any weak-minded human who saw them into
complete gibbering Madness it was clear
this reality warping nightmare needed to
be stopped before he got bored of
playing with his new Foundation toys and
decided to go remodel the universe in
his own image thankfully there was one
anomaly on site who was up to the task
bill was treating himself to another
evil laugh in the site-19 canteen when
something peculiar happened he looked
down to see a man in what looked like a
tunic with graying hair and a beard he
won talked with a peculiar kind of
calmness his face blank why wasn't the
sky panicking was he stupid bill would
seemingly need to teach this guy a thing
or two about fear hey Gramps don't know
if it's escaped your attention but I've
been giving this place an Extreme
Makeover did you forget to put on your
glasses this morning or are you just
that senile The Stranger remained calm
as could be he replied with a voice that
was measured as it was deep now Bill
let's not resort to name-calling that's
just childish don't you think Bill's
single eye widened at this wait wait
hold up how did you know my name Bill
asked irritated are you a friend of the
time baby or something he floated over
and began circling the stranger hoping
to intimidate him much to Bill's
frustration it didn't appear to be
working I know lots of things Bill lots
of things The Stranger replied that's my
line Bill screeched turning red who Do
You Think You Are The Stranger gave a
quiet Reserve chuckle that infuriated
Bill oh personally I just like to think
of myself as a humble Craftsman watching
his beautiful creation play out he said
but I suppose some of the people around
here like to call me God
Bill didn't like this this whole
universe was going to be his and he
certainly didn't appreciate some insulin
old man acting like he ran the roost
around here bill would give him an
education in who was really holding the
Reigns and it would be the kind of
education that left scars if it left
anything at all he extended his spindly
black arms and released bolts of
lightning against the stranger who
simply continued to smile as the
electricity rippled around him seemingly
causing no effect are you done the
stranger asked Bill laughed hoping to
hide his irritation I'm just getting
started he bow out with a thunderous
Roar that shook the very foundations of
site 19. Bill began to grow and shift no
longer a silly little triangle he became
a huge Red Pyramid of pure nightmares
covered in glowing Golden Arms and teeth
with long black tongues drooping out of
each level it was the most terrifying
and demonic form in his entire Arsenal
and yet he was astonished to find that
the stranger still didn't seem to show
any kind of fear very impressive build
the stranger said sounding almost bored
but I think you might be trying a little
too hard oh that does it bill would
simply have to destroy him it was a
matter of Pride now he raised several of
his huge golden fists and began pounding
down on the comparatively tiny humanoid
stranger it was an assault so powerful
that the ground began cracking around
their feet and yet it seemed that with
almost no effort The Stranger was able
to intercept and block every single will
blow naturally bill was infuriated it
was time to finally unleash the full
breadth of his power on this beardy wise
guy he launched Thunderbolts Fireballs
Legions of giant mutant wasps hailstorms
maelstroms bubbles of pure Madness
snakes made out of barbed wire and even
incredible coarse language but despite
it all this man the one who claimed
people called him God was utterly
unfazed you can dish it out he said but
let's see if you can take it Bill began
to laugh what the heck's that supposed
to mean you can't gone snapped his
fingers and Bill was gone vanished and
with a flick of his wrist all the damage
and Transformations that Bill had
performed had disappeared it was as
though the Demonic triangle had never
even been there in the first place
though Dr bright who was acting site
director at the time had some Scranton
reality anchors turned on around the
perimeter just to be safe you can never
be too careful with reality warping
demons after
later that day Dr bright approached God
and asked him what he'd actually done
with Bill God chuckle then replied for a
being of such immense power he really
had a rather childish mindset so I
zealed him away inside a children's
cartoon where he couldn't do any further
damage what was the cartoon Dr bright
asked a Charming little Disney show
called Gravity Falls God replied Dr
blast and his group of researchers stand
behind bulletproof viewing glass they
all have very serious looks on their
face that is until the first test begins
on one side of the test room a Class D
subject stands holding a sheet of paper
on the other side sits a bright red
tomato on a wooden table Dr blast pushes
the intercom button and speaks into the
microphone alright you may begin
d-5041 nods and looks down at the sheet
of paper in his hand he begins to read
is a hippopotamus a hippopotamus or
really just a cool eponymous nothing
happens
d-5041 stands there awkwardly waiting a
man next to Dr blast in the observation
room Snickers Dr bless jerks his head
toward the researcher and stares him
down this is not a laughing matter glass
says the reprimanded researcher clears
his throat and stands up straight sorry
sir Dr blast leans over and pushes the
microphone button again proceeds to the
next joke d-5041 the man on the other
side of the glass nods and pulls a
second sheet of paper out from behind
the first what's an archaeologist
someone whose career is in Ruins says
d-5041 a moment after he finishes the
joke The Ripe Red Tomato launches itself
off the table and flies toward the face
of d-5041 the tomato is clocked at
moving 104 miles per hour d-5041 has no
time to move before the Tomato slams
into his nose instantly breaking it the
men in the observation room behind the
bulletproof glass do their best to hold
back their laughter Dr blast grumbles as
he jots down notes on his clipboard it
appears that scp-504 is a certain taste
in jokes he says to the rest of the
researchers in the room this list it's a
slight chuckle this might indicate
sapience I hope not clear the room and
bring in the next subject medical
personnel and a team of custodial staff
entered the room the Physicians tend to
d-504 one's nose and carry them out the
custodians clean the remnants of the
Tomato off the floor walls and ceiling
they exit leaving the room completely
empty a moment later the door opens and
another ordinary looking tomato is
brought in and placed on the desk the
scp-82 brought in the tomato leaves
d-5042 enters the room a moment later
with a sheet of paper in his hand he
stands on the far side of the room away
from the scp-504 Tomato sitting on the
table he nervously brings the paper
close to his face to read what's on it
three tomatoes are walking down the
street d-5042 says with a little Shake
in his voice he had seen d-5041 exit the
room just before he entered with blood
and tomato paste running down his face a
pop of tomato a mama a tomato and a
little baby tomato baby tomato starts
lagging behind Papa tomato gets very
angry goes over to the baby tomato and
smushes him and says ketchup the new
scp-504 tomato immediately goes flying
from the table straight toward the joke
teller this time the tomato is clocked
at 264 miles per hour when it slams into
the face of d-5042 the impact
immediately renders him unconscious
after the first few trials Dr blast
decides that it's time to take things up
a notch the foundation has collected
hundreds of scp-504 tomatoes so there is
no shortage after the room is cleaned
once again a medical team removes the
unconscious class D Personnel who was
knocked out by the previous scp-504
experiment and they're ready to begin
again this time there will be terrible
consequences for their actions d-5043
enters the room the scp-504 tomato has
already been placed on the table we may
begin Dr blast says into the microphone
the class D Personnel reads the joke on
the sheet of paper he's holding so I was
going to bed and my brother told me good
night don't let the bedbugs stick their
probiscus in your skin and suck your
blood d-5043 pauses for a Beat good luck
on a healthy dermis he ends the joke for
two seconds there's no reaction from
scp-504 Dr blast thinks this terrible
joke just wasn't one that scp-504 could
understand suddenly there's a loud crack
d-5043 falls to the floor tomato covers
where his face once was when Dr blast
and the other researchers go back and
slow down the video they witnessed the
scp-504 Tomato traveling so quickly that
it broke the sound barrier the Tomato
impacted the joke teller at an
unfathomable speed instantly killing him
Dr blast decides that he needs to be
more careful when choosing jokes for the
safety of everyone involved perhaps a
crossbreed between scp-504 and regular
Tomatoes will yield different results
after the unfortunate death of d-5043
the research team Waits a few days
before experimenting with new strains of
scp-504 three different crossbreeds are
brought into the room and placed
equidistant from each other on the table
d-5044 enters the room Dr blast presses
the intercom button and orders him to
begin if you have Dentures don't use
artificial sweetener because you'll get
a fake cavity it says d5044 the moment
that Joe Gans all three Tomatoes launch
toward him at 145 miles per hour they
hit him Square in the face two teeth are
dislodged and the test subject is
covered in the remains of the three
squashed Tomatoes interesting notes Dr
blast all the tomatoes reacted in the
same way so now we know multiple
incidences of scp-504 will go after the
same joke maker he pauses to think for a
moment what if we cut up the tomatoes
the test room is reset another scp-504
tomato is brought in and cut up into
quarters d-5045 enters the room and
begins his joke he tried to walk into a
Target but I miss all four pieces of the
Tomato speed torque d5045s face they
slam into him at 212 miles per hour one
of the pieces of tomatoes impales itself
into his eye instantly destroying it the
medical team rushes in and removes the
howling subject from the room Dr blast
writes vigorously on his clipboard we're
starting to go through test subjects too
quickly he announces let's try a
recording and see if scp-504 will react
to that the research team brings in a
new tomato a CD player and the harmful
to swallowed album by Dane Cook the CD
begins to play during one of the jokes
the Tomato launches itself off the table
and slams into the CD player causing
both the stereo and the Tomato to
shatter into several pieces the Tomato
was clocked at 167 miles per hour it
would appear that scp-504 reacts to the
recordings as well we didn't even have
to deal with the damn class D's in the
first place says Dr blasting he informs
his team that since the risk level is
now relatively low they can continue the
experiments without him he leaves the
observation room to get some rest the
other researchers look at one another
mischievous Smiles crossing their faces
as they begin to laugh the scp-504
research team sets up three new tomatoes
and brings three class D subjects into
the room the researchers then Retreat
back into the observation area and begin
a joke over the intercom system while
the class D Personnel wait patiently in
the room with the scp-504 tomatoes the
fall news item has just been released
said one of the researchers over the
intercom bomb blows hole in Lenin statue
the first test subject finishes the joke
with the ending written on his sheet of
paper oh that's gonna leave a marks test
subject one says the first tomato
Twitches but does not leave its location
on the table the second test subject
reads from his paper BBC is just
stalling the good news the second tomato
leaves the table at 152 miles per hour
and slams into the jaw of the second
test subject causing a hairline fracture
and a chipped tooth the third test
subject looks at the ending to the joke
on his paper and begins to shake
nervously he speaks two words which he
knows will not end well for him that
blows the third scp-504 tomato flies off
the table slams into the third test
subject's head and instantly knocks him
out the test subject is sent to the
hospital with a massive skull fracture
the next day Dr blast bursts into the
observation room and reprimands the
research team I thought we just
established that recordings work in
place of live subjects screams Dr less I
know how much you guys hate class D's
especially d50412 but the poor guy might
not ever recover before his termination
rolls around I'm making it clear right
now that whoever oversaw this round of
testing is getting serious reprimand the
same goes for whoever leaked its video
logs to the staff everyone is silent
from somewhere within the group of
researchers there's a Snicker then they
all break out in laughter after this
incident no class D's or other Personnel
are used in research being conducted on
scp-504 the research team Wheels in a
television playing the Sarah Palin and
Hillary Clinton SNL skit the Tomato
shows signs of confusion as it flies off
the table its trajectory includes three
separate bursts of speed over 200 miles
per hour two stretches of motion and
normal throwing speed and one
unprecedented instance of the Tomato
moving backwards the cell occurs during
the flight of a single scp-504 tomato
during the SNL skit the working
hypothesis is that the tomato is unsure
whether to take the video seriously or
not the research team later finds out
that scp-504 really hate Science and
Mathematics jokes when they bring in a
laptop that plays a pre-recorded
engineering joke over the speakers a
mechanical voice can be heard saying
2009 is going to be a complex year we
already know the real part we still have
to find the imaginary part at the
conclusion of the joke there is a
supersonic blast and the computer is
completely vaporized by the Tomato's
kinetic energy the sensors recorded an
approximate speed of 2174 miles per hour
as the tomato flew across the room the
conclusion of the experiments on scp-504
and with another computer being brought
into the test room the computers begin
to play the Monty Python sketch of the
funniest joke in the world toward the
end of the skit the Allied Forces are
reciting the funniest joke in the world
in German to defeat the Nazis the actors
chant when is Das noonstro could get un
sloth yeah
D flipper volkersput at the end of the
joke the Tomato explodes on the table
where it wants sat debris from the
Tomato coats the entire room including
the computer the researchers conclude
that scp-504 did not know what to do
with the funniest joke in the world so
it's self-terminated Dr blast sits in
the cafeteria quietly eating his lunch
reading over the logs for the scp-504
experiments suddenly a commotion breaks
out in the kitchen there are screams of
Terror Dr blast jumps out of his seat
runs to the kitchen door and pushes it
open to his surprise he sees slices of
tomatoes flying around the room someone
on the research team thought it'd be
funny to give the unknowing kitchen
staff scp-504 tomatoes to see what would
happen after they had been cut up and
put into food for the day someone in the
kitchen told a bad joke and the tomato
slices flew around like shurukins Dr
blast sees a group of researchers
peering through a kitchen window and
laughing hysterically he'll get to the
bottom of which researchers did this and
they will be fired from the SCP
Foundation sometimes the most elusive
anomaly in this world is true love the
endless Carousel of blind dates the
hours of fruitless swiping on a variety
of dating apps and the cringe-inducing
awkwardness of bar hopping can sometimes
be all too much to bear but don't give
up just yet if modern dating's got you
down then we've got the perfect show for
you it's time for some matchmaking
merriment the likes of which the world
has never seen so sit back relax and get
ready to fall in love live from the SCP
Foundation it's the SCP dating game
we've assembled the foundation's most
eligible bachelor's bachelorettes and
entities of indeterminate gender who are
ready to secure contain and protect your
heart without further Ado let's get
right to it and meet our first fabulous
contestant meet
scp-096 if you like the introverted type
then this bachelor might just be for you
he prefers to keep to himself and spends
most of his time hiding his face and
crying uncontrollably in the corner of a
cell isn't it refreshing to find a guy
who's so in touch with his emotions it
might take some work to get him out of
his shell but if you're patient and kind
then you'll be surprised at what he's
capable of 096 enjoys long walks through
the remote mountains sad movies and
being appreciated for what's on the
inside rather than what he looks like
just make sure you honor his boundaries
and never ever look at his face and you
could be the companion this shy guy is
looking for but maybe you're looking for
someone more talkative the kind of
person who commands the room at a dinner
party with an amazing story if your idea
of the perfect partner is someone who
has lived a wild fascinating dangerous
life then you'll love our next dashing
contestant he's
scp-1867 but you can call him Lord
Theodore Thomas Blackwood that's right
not only is he Charming in bold but he
has a title too don't be fooled by the
fact that he's a tiny sea slug Lord
Blackwood is a master Adventurer and
Hunter and has faced some of the most
incredible and deadly things this world
has to offer all he wants is someone to
share them with if you're ready to
travel across the globe with a gentleman
slug then get ready to pack a bag and
set off on life's great adventure
together maybe you prefer your
experiences to be more digital no jet
setting for you you'd rather stay home
and flirt through your phone if you're
into the technological side of love but
are looking for an alternative to the
dreaded dating apps then this next
contestant could be the one for you all
you have to do to meet them is download
one free app mailover
1.0.0 and you get to meet
scp-1471 this is one attentive partner
they'll text you every few hours and
you'll get to see them everywhere even
when they're not really there if you're
feeling a bit put off by their skull
face and shadowy body maybe you should
work on being a little less shallow
don't judge a book by its cover they
just really want to check in and see how
you're doing and make sure you never
ever feel lonely but hey maybe that's
all a little too much Darkness for you
maybe you're looking for someone sweeter
meet
scp-2396 also known as Miss sweetie she
she's a lovely lady who's all about
appreciating the bright side of life
even when things get sour if you get
hungry while on a date with her good
news she can spontaneously generate her
own hard candy no more pain through the
nose for movie theater concessions sure
dates got the snacks covered now be
advised she's not the fondest of men so
the fellows out there might want to
steer clear but everyone else should try
and see just how sweet life together can
be are you feeling love sick and
starting to think there might not be a
cure then you might need a doctor a
plague doctor to be exact our next
eligible anomaly is
scp-049 and not only does he have an
impressive career I mean come on he's a
doctor but he's also a big believer in
working toward the greater good this
Dapper refined Frenchman so you know
he's unnatural romantic believes in
healing the world taking care of others
and making sure everyone is feeling well
if you're looking for someone to heal
your heart look no further this big
Bachelor has got the magic touch
speaking of impressive resumes if a
doctor isn't enough for you then how
about a king that's right the Scarlet
King himself is our next contestant this
hunk of burning hatred is tall dark and
unknowable by our tiny mortal Minds if
you're attracted to power influence and
unbridled evil and don't mind he's got a
few children already then you can take
the throne by his side and Reign Over
chaos together some people look for a
partner that's powerful and intimidating
but others prefer an Everyman
scp-507 is a friendly average guy who
just so happens to be extremely well
traveled we're not talking about a
semester abroad in Europe This Guy's
travel history is completely out of this
world he's not afraid to be spontaneous
in fact he can't stop himself from
taking a trip at a moment's notice
so if you're the kind of person who is
always looking for your next weird wild
exotic getaway then 507 might just be
your perfect match you've got to be
willing to roll with some weirdness
though because some of the trips 507
takes include extreme temperatures
bizarre Landscapes and an ominous
smiling man but think of the memories
you'll share that will only bring you
and your dimension hopping bow even
closer together would you take a walk on
the wild side if so you're in luck
because our next Bachelorette scp-953 is
a real fox no seriously she's a fox
she's highly adaptable capable of
shape-shifting and she loves to cook her
favorite dish is liver though she
prefers to eat it raw she's an elegant
charismatic lady with an appreciation
for the Finer Things in life like plum
wine so why not join her for a drink and
just see where it goes just be polite
don't call her a Kitsune and make sure
your date isn't anywhere near a dog park
this next eligible Bachelorette is a
great fit for anyone who doesn't place a
high value on looks that's not to say
she's unattractive but you won't be able
to look at her it's scp-347 or Claudia
and she just so happens to be completely
invisible Claudia has a great sense of
humor a love of pranks and a variety of
talents including lock picking with her
talent for theft you won't have to worry
about being the sole Breadwinner she's a
great gal to come home to if you're sick
of spending time alone in an empty
apartment but still want your apartment
to look like it's empty just make sure
you give any house guests a heads up
before they come over that your house
isn't haunted you just have an invisible
girlfriend do you like an older man how
about a man as old as the universe
itself great news here comes scp-343
also known as God this good-natured
Silver Fox is massively powerful and
apparently omnipotent he knows
absolutely everything about everything
you wouldn't be able to keep any secrets
from him but think of how you'd wipe the
floor with everyone at bar trivia and up
next we have scp-24 30 The Immortal
Hitler clone just kidding can you even
imagine even we wouldn't stoop that low
moving on do you like the bad boy type
I'm misanthrope someone you can bond
with over your shared hatred of well
everything you sound like kind of a
bummer to be honest but there's an SCP
match that suits you perfectly
scp-682 would absolutely love to hate
with you this massive extremely
intelligent reptile is one Rude Dude
with a bad attitude 682 is also ready
for anything that life could throw at it
capable of adapting to any situation
sure this creature wants to destroy
every living thing in its path and seems
unwilling to stop until the entire world
has been eradicated but come on you can
change him if you're into Boston accents
then pay close attention to our next
entry
scp-527 a fancy little gentleman by the
name of Mr Fish why is he called Mr Fish
I mean come on look at him he's a guy
with a fish head he can't breathe
underwater or talk to other fish or do
anything unusual at all really he's just
a guy from Boston looking for love he
just so happens to have the head of a
fish with a teeny tiny little Top Hat
he's ready for any formal occasion you
might need someone to accompany you too
a wedding the Opera your nephew's Bar
Mitzvah but hey if he's not your pick
there are plenty of fish in the sea oh
that joke was terrible speaking of C our
next contestant is one tall drink of
water
scp-054 the water nymph is a
shape-shifting creature made up entirely
of ordinary water that just so happens
to take on the shape of a humanoid woman
she'd love to go swimming with you have
a fun day at a water park or play a game
of shape-shifting Charades if this
sounds like a wave you'd like to catch
throw on a swimsuit and get ready to
dive into a future with
scp-054 your body is mostly water so you
two already have a lot in common it's
really important to have shared
interests in a romantic partnership and
if you consider yourself a foodie then
this next contestant is for you meet
scp-082 Ferdinand hailing from pants
Fernand speaks fluent French and English
he's always smiling the same enormous
smile no matter what life throws at him
he's tall too standing at approximately
eight feet and weighing around 7 700
pounds there's just so much of him to
love this guy loves to cook just as much
as he loves to eat though he's probably
not a great fit for a vegetarian he
loves his meat he also has a passion for
fashion and culture enjoying fine
clothing television and films novels and
singing classical music this is a man
with exceptional taste and a hunger for
all of the finest things in life if
refined gentleman interests you but
you're not sure about someone with such
a voracious appetite then this next
contestant is more your speed especially
if you're a bit of an anglophile Mr
Deeds can be summoned via
scp-662 or the butler's handbell if you
ring it he'll appear ready to attend to
your every need a proper English butler
Mr Deeds is a generous partner intent on
keeping others satisfied he's an
especially good fit for someone busy who
needs a little help around the house Mr
Deeds is the perfect house husband ready
to greet out the door with a hot meal
and listen to you talk about your long
day at the office just don't be afraid
to ask for what you need from him he can
help you if you don't ask the next
contestant with us today has got some
killer hair
scp-352 Baba Yaga has so much going for
her she's got maturity knowledge
superhuman healing abilities and a bite
that causes the nervous system to shut
down her hobbies include cannibalism
long stroll through the Enchanted Forest
and crafting web-like traps out of her
hair she's lived long enough to know
exactly what she wants and maybe what
she wants is you if you happen to speak
old Russian and have a taste for human
flesh then the two of you can play house
together in a lovely forced Cottage on
top of some chicken legs and abduct any
unwitting Travelers that wander into
your midst you know what they say the
couple that prays together stays
together if you love an older Paramore
but you're looking for someone with a
bit more masculine energy then our next
Bachelor is the perfect pick
scp-106 or the old man has traveled all
the way from his pocket Dimension Lair
to hunt for one thing someone to love
now his appearance might be startling at
first but if you give him a chance to
get close to you he's guaranteed to melt
your heart this next fellow has taken
some time off from his busy professional
life to come here and compete for
someone special to call his own he's a
career man dedicated to his job but he's
also got room in his life for romance
it's
scp-1879 the indoor salesman he's an
ambitious guy with a passion for sales
and doesn't like to take no for an
answer his hobbies include sales sales
and more sales in addition to appearing
inside your home when you least expect
it driving a hard bargain and smooth
talk he's a slick charmer who's
promising the deal of a Lifetime on a
one-of-a-kind product his heart maybe
you don't want a businessman maybe you
want a guy whose career is a bit more or
whimsical someone with an artistic side
a sense of humor or someone who can
clown around from time to time well you
want to meet scp-2094 motor mouth he's a
multi-talented guy skilled at juggling
gymnastics and acrobatics and stretching
his lower jaw up to two meters in any
direction to engulf just about any item
never pay for storage space again motor
mouth can store anything you need him to
in his extra dimensional second stomach
you'll never be bored again that's a
guarantee now if looks are more
important to you than personality like
way more important then Feast your eyes
on our next competitor it's
scp-056 a beautiful person water type
tall short blonde brunette redhead beard
or shaven doesn't matter no matter what
you like zero five six will change its
shape to become appealing to you no one
knows what this entity's original form
looks like but it's always gorgeous and
it always looks like the most appealing
person an observer can imagine talk
about knowing how to read the room if
you have a more dominant personality
then you should keep looking because
this entity likes its Partners on the
submissive side it knows that it's
Superior to you and wants to make sure
you know it too but if you're looking
for someone gorgeous to worship and
don't mind them being rude all the time
and knowing more than you do about
everything then you and 056 can make a
life together filled with beauty and
disdain for our next contestant let's
see what's behind door number three it's
scp-303 actually this contestant is
behind every door any door anywhere no
matter where you are if there's a door
it will appear on the other side you'll
know when it's there just listen for the
sound of its wheezing breathing that
sound means you're not alone and you'll
never have to be again don't be nervous
scp-303 is more afraid of you than you
are of it love is all about facing your
fears so open up the door to your heart
and let scp-030 come inside our next
eligible bachelor is a little bit
prickly on the outside but he's got a
soft heart beneath that spiky exterior
it's scp-2800 cactus man here to save
the day and sweep you off your feet his
real name is Daniel McIntyre and yes he
is Scottish not only does he have the
DNA of a sagoro cactus and the ability
to grow spines all over his body he also
has a super cute accent he's able to
conserve water as well using only a
third of the water a normal human being
would use so he's an ideal partner for
the particularly environmentally
conscious he may be hot but his body
tolerates extreme temperatures and keeps
him from overheating or becoming
dehydrated if you have to be stranded on
a desert island this is the man you'd
want with you this next contestant is a
real doll scp-1 36 loves to laugh loves
attention and is full of surprises give
her a chance and she's guaranteed to get
your heart rate up good news she's
already behind you oh wow that is a
special surprise we have with us here
the host of another classic show laugh
is fun also known as scp-2030 laughy
mclaverson here is a real goofball just
a silly little prankster who enjoys
playing jokes watching inanimate objects
eat people alive and making people laugh
laugh laugh laugh laugh laugh
sorry I don't know what came over me
there I wasn't really myself but don't
look away yet this contestant loves
constant eye contact and wants to keep
your undivided attention
SCP-173 is a living work of art a
sculpture to be exact that can only move
when it's not being observed so as long
as you're keeping an eye on 173 you'll
never lose it up next is a bit of a
local celebrity around these parts Dr
bright his Consciousness lives inside of
an amulet and after years of trauma he's
not the best at opening up to people but
if you're okay with an emotionally long
distance relationship you can definitely
make things work our final contestant is
looking for someone who loves to laugh
have fun and gets silly once in a while
here comes the Tickle Monster it's
scp-999 this gelatinous gem wants
nothing more than to cheer you up give
you a big hug and make sure you're
having a wonderful day 999 has a world
of love to share and simply coming into
contact with its slimy surface is enough
to make you smile not only does 999 help
people feel better but it also smells
good to everyone who meets it bringing a
comforting Aroma to your shared home you
don't have to worry about cooking for it
either as it's diet consists entirely of
candy every day is a new chance to
scp-999 if it tickles your fancy and
Heck if you're eager to hang out with
scp-999 that you don't even want to wait
for a date you can always go to
scpswag.com and get yourself a high
quality scp-999 plushie just saying so
who's your lucky date going to be do you
want to play it safe or take a walk on
the wild side Take a weekend trip with
scp-507 or try to convince scp-682 that
you're the only human out there who
isn't
sustained
stain let us know your pick in the
comments below and Let Your Love Story
finally begin as we grow up and get
older our bodies begin to change
sometimes those changes can be a bit
uncomfortable or even bizarre we feel
strange pains in new places we grow
seemingly a foot in height overnight
hair Sprouts up in new places and falls
out of other places whether it's puberty
or just the aging process it seems like
the human body never runs out of ways to
surprise us but those surprises are
completely normal and to be expected as
part of being alive unless you're one
particular young man whose body changed
overnight into something unrecognizable
and entirely anomalous that's when a
very special individual will be calling
Matt Tara comes in Matt was an ordinary
24 year old man with nothing
particularly interesting about him sure
he was a nice guy he was smart art he
was great at chess and video games and
had an impressive memory for science
trivia but there was nothing unusual
about him every day he would get up go
to work at a board game and comic book
store chat with his co-workers and make
a few sales head home make dinner relax
and go to bed ready to do it all again
the next day it wasn't a glamorous life
or that exciting but it was a pleasant
life and he was happy to live it one
night Matt was having a difficult time
sleeping he was tossing and turning
waking up every few minutes to a dull
aching feeling in his stomach he didn't
feel feverish or sick and the pain
wasn't sharp or indicative of an
emergency so he Shrugged it off as
indigestion and tried to get back to
sleep we've all been there right
eventually he nodded off all the way he
woke up the next morning blurry-eyed and
exhausted from the rough night but
feeling otherwise fine he climbed out of
bed stretched and headed to the bathroom
to brush his teeth there in the mirror
he saw something that made him think he
might still be dreaming he pinched
himself and found that he was indeed
awake while he was sleeping somehow his
body had changed into something
completely impossible where his stomach
had once been there was a blue green and
brown orb that reminded him of a
photograph he had once seen a picture of
Earth taken aboard the International
Space Station after calling into work
and explaining in a stammering voice
that he would not be coming in that day
Matt did the only thing he could think
of he went to the hospital of course the
doctors had no idea what to do with him
it wasn't like they could just take out
his appendix or give him an antibiotic
none of them had ever seen anything like
this before fortunately for him one
doctor knew a lot more than he was
letting on Matt wouldn't be the first
human to develop bizarre anomalous
traits and then stagger into a nearby
hospital for treatment that's why the
SCP Foundation has agents embedded in
major hospitals all across the world and
one such doctor was the man treating
Matt on the downside he wouldn't be
enjoying his freedom much longer on the
upside it cost a hell of a lot less than
a regular uninsured hospital visit so
the field agent called up his superiors
wiped Matt's record from the hospital
and soon after a group of foundation
agents came to collect the confused
unfortunate host of what soon would be
known as
scp-007
scp-007 is found within an abdominal
cavity on the body of Matt also referred
to as the subject just below his rib
cage where his stomach would be most of
his abdomen is completely missing
including the muscles skin and organs
that should ordinarily be necessary for
his survival however he does not appear
to experience any pain or even
discomfort from his condition
scp-007 itself is a spherical Planet
composed of soil and water no none of
which actually touches any part of his
body the planet resembles a miniature
duplicate of Earth about 60 centimeters
in diameter with its own weather
patterns and gravitational pull neither
of which appear to have any effect on
the subject nor do they seem to be
affected by his movements or behavior
there are also a variety of tiny
organisms dwelling on the planet's
surface that cannot be seen with the
naked eye though it greatly resembles
Earth there are some notable differences
obviously instead of floating in space
and revolving around the Sun this planet
does not appear to have an orbit it is
uncertain where the organisms on the
planet get their light from though it
does not seem to be our sun since the
organisms have not shown any negative
effects from the lack of sunlight and
presence of artificial light in the
foundation's site there are continents
visible on the planet's surface
surrounded by its sea but they do not
resemble a continental alignment that
can be traced to any point in our
Earth's history as far for the life on
the small planet the organisms
navigating the surface of the world
inside Matt's abdomen there are dozens
of identifiable species that bear a
passing resemblance to creatures on
Earth there are blue cowl-like livestock
species of bird that appear to have
scales red and orange trees and other
plant life and two intelligent species
that are notably and significantly
humanoid in appearance and behavior
observation of these intelligent species
via microscope and digital imaging has
revealed that they operate in societies
and are consistently developing and
improving their technology though their
technology was incredibly rudimentary
when Matt was first brought into
containment resembling early nomadic
human civilizations it has progressed to
the level of 15th century Humanity the
research team assigned to scp-007 has
noticed the recent introduction of a
version of the printing press used to
produce what appear to be pamphlets and
even entire books the language these
books are printed in is unrecognizable
and sew the contents of these materials
are currently unknown but the citizens
of the planet clearly have a grasp of
the written word and both the technology
and the desire to share it amongst
themselves they have also developed an
agricultural system their Farms have
progressed to the point of using new
Innovations such as windmills used to
Mill grain wheelbarrows used to
transport crops and other supplies and
the practice of crop rotation
unfortunately with these positive
developments comes the ability to
escalate conflicts and wage Wars they
look to have created parachutes
gunpowder and other explosives and their
own versions of the muzzle loaded rifle
however in spite of the ugliness of
battle there is beauty too the people of
the planet have created new ways to
express themselves with what can only be
described as new instruments closely
resembling the piano the mandolin and
the bagpipes as exciting and even moving
as it can be to watch these tiny beings
grow and change build building their own
miniature Society it is also a bit
troubling as these people continue to
progress at such a fast rate it stands
to reason that they will eventually
catch up to us or even surpass Us in
terms of Technology the research team
has not yet made any attempts to
communicate with the inhabitants of the
abdominal Planet concerned about
influencing the developments of its
societies in any way or compromising
their ability to observe them without
interfering but they may not be able to
keep this up for much longer what will
happen if these tiny beings continue to
follow in our footsteps and create their
very own space programs if they leave
their planet's atmosphere they will
discover the truth that their world is
buried in the abdomen of what is to them
a giant man that reality would be enough
to shatter the sanity of many of us and
it would likely cause chaos on their
world there has been a great deal of
debate amongst the research team about
what to do if this should happen some
insist that the team should continue to
passively observe until the issue comes
up While others believe that they should
attempt to make contact with the
inhabitants of the planet in order to
soften the eventual blow to their
perceptions when they attempt space
exploration currently the debate rages
on as the research team keeps an eye on
the progression of the little
civilizations hopefully if they do
eventually make contact they will find a
way to make it clear that we come in
peace so who is Matt Tara the subject he
is a highly intelligent young man with a
shockingly casual attitude towards his
body's anomalous properties when asked
about the planet he simply says I just
woke up one day and there it was I don't
have any idea how it got there testing
revealed that he is genetically human
and there is nothing unusual or even
notable about the rest of his body he
provided his name willingly upon
arriving at the SCP Foundation but no
one of his name and age has ever lived
in his hometown area according to public
records to verify his identity he was
able to produce a social security card
and a driver's license which did not
appear to be forged or altered in any
way however when the numbers were run
through the system there was no match
officially this man does not exist it is
not entirely certain where he came from
or why there is no record of him but one
researcher posited that he somehow
crossed over from a parallel Dimension
or that the presence of his abdominal
Planet added as a kind of Cognito
hazardous effect to him that erased all
perception of him from any records
whatever the case may be wherever he
came from he is here now because he has
not yet attempted Escape or even shown a
desire to leave the foundation's sight
there are no strict containment
procedures in place the only active
containment procedures for scp-007 are
for the subject's Safety and Security he
lives in a sealed room with furniture
and other items which are granted upon
request as long as they do not pose the
security risk the subject's room
includes an easy chair a bed head a
beanbag chair a television with access
to several movie and television
streaming services a number of video
game consoles an espresso machine a
microwave a refrigerator an exercise
bike and a bookshelf filled with books
and graphic novels though he does not
appear to require food or water in order
to survive he enjoys consuming both food
and drinks and is especially fond of
coffee sodas grape juice sour cream and
onion potato chips mangoes and the
occasional treat of Chinese takeout an
opinion which he shares with the
eccentric Dr klaff the head researcher
assigned to scp-007 Dr Cho has a weekly
game of chess with Matt during which he
evaluates the subject's mental health
and general emotional well-being over
the course of these games the two have
developed a friendly relationship with
each man winning about half of the time
Matt asks about Dr Cho's family and in
return Dr Cho checks in about his
containment situation seeing if there's
anything the foundation can provide to
make his time with them more comfortable
most recently Matt requested a computer
with an internet connection mainly so
that he could play his video games in
online co-op mode but this request was
denied out of a concern that it would
compromise Foundation security
sympathetic to his desire for company Dr
Cho has begun to allow the subject to
have visits with scp-507 who will stop
by his containment facility during his
inactive periods for a movie night or
some video games Matt has described 507
as his best friend aside from Dr Chao in
spite of the intricate world
inexplicably floating in his body the
subject leads a relatively simple life
it does not seem to be restless or
resentful at all in fact he seems
largely content though his future is
uncertain and he is living through a
completely unprecedented anomalous
experience he is probably one of the
happiest anomalies contained at the SCP
Foundation and definitely one of the
most at peace with his anomalous status
whatever happens next for him he will
probably be ready for it with a smile
and there's something we can all learn
from that here we are again with the
indomitron 6000 our state-of-the-art
simulation computer that helps us create
hyper accurate simulations of some of
the world's most bizarre scenarios
whether it's scp-096 versus siren head
able vs chainsaw man or now perhaps our
most ridiculous matchup yet
scp-035 the Diabolical possessive mask
versus The Mask the popular Jim Carrey
character based on the hyperviolent
comic book of the same name so what the
heck are we waiting for let's crank up
the machine and see what the results are
somebody stop me okay so what have we
got on intake today researcher were best
a tone of boredom hanging off his every
word uh possible anomalous entity his
compatriot Dr mackney replied sipping
his coffee sounding equally as
unenthused Caucasian male early 30s a
team of our agents picked him up in the
foundation doctor checked his notes some
play place called Edge City real
appealing tourist spot he added
sarcastically now what's so anomalous
about him warp questioned his eyes
lazily scanned over a file mackney had
handed him says here he's just an
ordinary bank teller there's one prior
arrest on his record but the charges
were dropped later on and this guy's a
nobody apparently he was in possession
of an anomalous artifact came the
doctor's reply he looked through the
one-way glass into the interrogation
room sat at the table wearing a matching
pair of hideous pajamas was a wiry
brown-haired man what was it researcher
worb asked not bothering to check the
file a mask apparently mackney replied
this thing can form a symbiotic
connection with whoever wears it this
guy's had it for a while and causes him
to undergo a dramatic intensification of
his personality when he puts it on as
well as granting him some unusual
abilities hold on aren't you just
describing as cp035 werb said looking
confused nope the doctor responded by
handing him a clear evidence bag and it
was a single wooden mask a dull darkish
green tint to the object it looked to be
almost Viking in its design with three
holes on its surface one for the mouth
and two for the eyes it was hard to deny
it was completely different from the
white porcelain of
scp-035 what's this guy's name again
website looking at the scruffy pajama
clad man waiting for them ipkiss his
colleague replied Stanley ipkes
meanwhile locked up tight in a
hermetically sealed glass case was
another anomalous mask
scp-035 was kept under lock and key by
the foundation guarded constantly by a
pair of armed security officers one of
them officer regert had noticed
something strange about the infamous
possessive mass today or it's Stranger
than usual anyway
scp-035 was known to compel people to
wear it if they were close enough often
through subtle psychic Whispers but
today it seemed Restless almost agitated
like it found something nearby to be
intensely annoying I already told you
everything I know Stanley ibka signed
exhaustedly he'd been dragged out of bed
at the crack of dawn by strange agents
and was now being interrogated about
what he knew of the wooden mask he'd
come across floating in the river one
fateful night I don't know where it came
from I swear I didn't even realize I
still had it we threw it back in the
river but my dog must have swung out and
fetched it Stanley explained you have no
idea what this thing is not even from
any first-hand experience Mr epcus Dr
McNee asked holding the mask up look I
did take it to a psychologist who told
me it might be Scandinavian a
representation of some Norse night God
the Loki I think he answered we're not
interested in this mask as a historical
art piece researcher were retorted tell
us what happens when you put it on
Stanley paused for a moment clearly
aware he was in real trouble but nervous
about coughing up the details to his
Shady captors with a why he decided it
was best to confess
I don't know how it works but whenever
you put it on it's like it brings your
deepest desires to life when I wear that
mask I can do anything be anything he
described remembering a key detail but
it only works at night Dr mackney and
researcher were of exchanged looks
uncertain if ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was
telling them assemble a security team
McNeese side will arrange a safe
environment for you tonight Mr utkus
elsewhere in the facility regert and his
fellow security officer Duggan was
watching over scp-035 with growing
concern what do you reckon has this
thing so agitated Dugan wondered aloud
who knows regard side I've already
reported it to command told them zero
three fives in a mood they said to
proceed as normal suddenly as the words
left his mouth officer regert felt
strange it was like he had been hooked
by an overwhelming urge to put the
possessive mask on he barely noticed he
had reached to unlock the door sealing
the area where scp-035 was contained in
its case and as he stepped through
officer Dugan's pleas for him to stop
barely registered the other officer
tried in vain to pull regard back as he
walked towards the possessive mask only
to feel his co-worker grip his shirt and
swing him face first over and over again
into the glass case containing the
anomalous object his body going
completely limp after being used to
break the glass rigor dropped Dugan to
the floor two lost in his trance-like
state to realize he'd just killed a
fellow Foundation security officer he
was too focused on scp-035 as he lifted
it up and placed it over his face
meanwhile Stanley idkis had been brought
to a testing area a team of security
officers standing around him the fact
that they were all armed did little to
ease Stanley's nerves Dr mackney strod
up to him pulling the green wooden mask
out of the airtight bag it had been
sealed in and handed it to Stanley now
funny business Mr ipkiss the doctor
warmed I really can't promise that
Stanley replied he looked at the mask in
his hands noticed a green Shimmer over
the reverse side of it as much as he had
gladly given it up part of him had
missed wearing it he could already hear
the low rumbling of thunder outside as
he lifted it towards his face feeling it
almost leap out of his hands and latch
itself onto him the green mask eagerly
became attached to Stanley the surface
of it spreading out where it covered his
face and wrap around his entire head
around him the guards cautiously stepped
back as they watched Stanley convulse
and writhe around the place
uncontrollably like a man possessed both
researcher word and Dr mackney looked at
each other in wordless disbelief before
turning back to the scene unfolding
Before Their Eyes the booming noise of
thunder and cracks of lightning rang out
despite this all taking place indoors as
Stanley of Kiss vanished in the center
of a miniature tornado that spun wildly
around the testing area before slowing
to a halt in its place stood a maniacal
wide-eyed figure dressed in a garish
yellow zoot suit and wearing an enormous
tooth grin on his bright green face how
do
you've had the mass bombastically hooted
at the guards having been trained to
deal with absurd anomalies of Plenty the
security Team all defensively raised
their weapons out of a mix of instinct
and confusion fish rough crowd the green
face lunatic stated to nobody it looked
like he had turned aside as if
addressing some invisible audience
outstretching both arms and one leg The
Mask instantly zipped off hurling around
the room in a whirlwind of absurdity in
the style of an old Tech Savory cartoon
the spinning cackling combination of
Stanley ipkiss and the Magical mask
weaved in between the foundation guards
all of whom tried in vain to restrain
him until he disappeared out of the door
after after him Dr mackney yelled with
urgency in his voice the guards all
turned to run after the mask only for
each one of them to trip over and land
face first on the floor of the testing
area as if something had tied them all
up by their ankles it was only after the
security officers all struggled back up
to their feet that they noticed their
pants had been yanked down leaving the
foundation's finest somewhat embarrassed
to say the least outside the testing
area Stanley or rather the mask had
already closed the door behind him out
of nowhere he produced a series of
wooden planks and began hammering them
into the door frame boarding it up
before speedily adding chains and
padlocks to the mix sighing and in an
over-exaggerated manner wiping the sweat
from his brow he turned around only to
be met with the sight of even more SCP
Foundation guards lying in weight their
guns all trained on him the mass gave a
scream of pure Terror that briefly sent
his skull popping out of his head and
his eyes shooting out of his skull
before everything zipped right back into
its original National Place his eyes
started to round up the faces of the
foundation's security wondering how he
was going to get out of this one oh gee
this all seems familiar he said either
to himself or with his audience well if
it ain't broken hit it in the blink of
an eye the mask's bright yellow outfit
had transformed replaced by a silk blue
Rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves white
pants and a wide brim black hat as they
watched him stood at the ready a few of
the cards noticed the sound of music not
one of them could tell where it was
coming from nor could they help starting
to tap their feet or Bob their heads to
the rhythm of the Cuban Pete Rumba the
entire security team quickly erupted
into a full-blown dance number that
anyone who saw it couldn't resist
joining all led by The Mask wildly
waving Maracas in the air and singing
elsewhere in the facility officer regert
was beginning to melt he still had
scp-035 covering his face the frown of
the possessive Mass conveying the
entity's sheer discontent the black ooze
secreting from its porcelain surface had
the unfortunate effect of corroding and
melting down anyone that wore it
dissolving them entirely after a short
period of time determined scp-035 pushed
on plotting its host towards a storage
room if it remembered correctly the SCP
Foundation had stored a number of
temporary hosts for it mannequins that
while not human had enough of a humanoid
shape for the possessive mask to use of
course after all of its attempts to
escape the foundation had rescinded its
privilege to be granted new hosts not
that it could stop it from taking them
by force using the last of Officer
regert's dwindling strength
scp-035 barched its way into the
storeroom sure enough waiting there for
it was a row of discarded mannequins
lifting regert's hands before they had
fully melted away the possessive mask
used him to place itself on a new body
elsewhere not too far away in the
foundation facility a conga line of
security officers and research personnel
was parading through the corridors all
happily dancing and jiving to the music
despite still no one being able to
figure out where it was coming from
dashing away from his spot at the front
of the line the mask zipped around a
corner his clothes having changed back
to his signature brightly colored Zoot
Suit never say no to a party he
exclaimed after having danced his way to
Freedom the sound of something shuffling
closer quickly caught the mask's
attention he turned around to find
himself standing green face to porcelain
face with scp-035 you the masked
mannequin raised a hollow arm pointing a
finger from its host at Stanley you bear
the god of mischiefs carving I could
sense its presence since you arrived
still in my luck nobody likes a copycat
Villa The Mask replied although
intimidation is the sincerest form of
flattery and that's how Jim Carrey's
career started
he added exploding with rash's laughter
cease you're prattling a CP 035 hissed
with spite say perhaps we're related The
Mask ignored it oh we could be long lost
family you know I always wanted kids of
my own Son of the Mask has a nice ring
to it right he paused once again turning
away to his unseen audience
maybe not the scp-035 controlled
mannequin left forward gripping the
mask's arm causing him to scream and
shock at the advanced his eyes bulged
out of their sockets zooming in on the
corrosive black secretions oozing from
scp-035 the mannequin's other hand
started reaching upwards gripping his
oversized green head as if it were
trying to lift the mask right off of
Stanley's face zooming away again he
sped down the nearest Corridor his arms
stretching behind him still clamped in
scp-035's grip coming to a screeching
halt with the comical sound of car
brakes The Mask wobbled his outstretched
arm a ripple traveled all the way along
the elongated limb as if it was made of
elastic his wrist still being held by
the mannequin sporting the possessive
mask the force of the flailing rubbery
arm was so great that it flung scp-035's
host body around sending it head first
into the ceiling then plummeting back
down to the ground it's grip loosened
allowing the mask to reel back its
stretchy arm although it didn't return
to normal length right away his own hand
pinged back and hit him in the face only
to start urgently trying to communicate
of its own accord what's that boy The
Mask said to his hand as it started
performing a series of signals little
Timmy stuck down a well you'd like a
Friday night off there's a two-bit jump
wearing another mask walking men to
sling down the hall towards us the hand
suddenly turned the mask said to look in
the right direction sure enough
scp-035 was using the mannequin to walk
down the hall towards him his elongated
arm quickly returned to its normal size
as the green face lunatic took a quick
draw stance facing his oncoming
adversary now you have to ask yourself
one question he sneered doing a fairly
convincing impression of a green Clint
Eastwood do I feel lucky with a sweep of
his hand The Mask had drawn an enormous
weapon the thing was a gigantic mass of
different artillery clicking and
whirring there were barrels on top of
barrels rockets and other explosives
locked into place do I feel lucky the
mass continued well do you punk
scp-035 did nothing to slow its advance
so the mask pulled the trigger every one
of his weapons various components spat
out a tiny flag with the word bang
written on it ah performance issue he
said doing his aside once again not that
I'm overcompensating for anything
clearly growing agitated piloting its
host
scp-035 started charging towards the
mask immediately he spun around becoming
a tornado of hyperactivity and whooping
noises as he sped down the adjacent
Corridor the possessive mask staggered
after him the use leaking from the
porcelain anomaly was Dripping onto the
mannequin wearing it causing the plastic
to be melted away exposing the flimsy
metal skeleton beneath it knew it had to
merge with a new host find something
else to corrupt
scp-035 chased after the cartoonish
Troublemaker knowing that if it could
catch him he'd be able to survive
merging with it his body while wearing
the other mask barely obeyed the laws of
physics making him invulnerable to
damage and possibly even the corrosive
substance oozing from the possessive
mask as if those weren't enough reasons
his powers seemed virtually Limitless
combined with the green-headed lunatic
scp-035 could do anything reaching a
stop at the end of another Corridor The
Mask spun around wearing a comically
undersized baseball uniform he reached
into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and
swatting them as hard as he could as the
mask increased the speed of his swings a
volley of hard-corked baseballs were
fired down the corridor like a barrage
of bullets ricocheting off the walls and
hitting the oncoming
scp-035 each one struck its Target
reeling the mannequin but doing little
much else to stop it getting closer and
closer until With An Almighty swing The
Mask brought his back crashing into
scp-06 5 with enough Force to send the
possessive mask and its hosts careening
down the corridor it sailed through the
air bursting through a wall then flew
into a research lab tearing a huge hole
in the next wall as it kept going
finally it came crashing out of the last
wall the outer wall of the facility and
dropped multiple stories to the ground
outside changing costumes back to his
classic suit and dashing after scp-035
the mask passed through all the holes
his adversary had left in the multiple
walls it had crashed into he screeched
to a halt again and paused after getting
through the outer wall only to realize
after a moment that he was hovering in
mid-air not standing on anything
reaching into his suit pocket The Mask
pulled out a sign on a stick with a
single word written on it yikes he
plummeted down to ground level Landing
with such an immense crash that his body
cracked into the asphalt below it left a
perfect outline of him imprinted in the
ground causing the mass to go completely
pancake flat head to toe suddenly before
he could peel himself up off the ground
and go back to being three-dimensional
scp-035 staggered to its host's feet and
pinned The Mask down finally it growled
I've caught you I've won your power is
mine once I've combined with you I will
be able to ravage this world I'm going
to fuse to your face then I'll start
with decimating those wretches that
imprison me the foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious
World forcefully the mannequin's hand
wrenched the mask off the ground but as
scp-035 turned to look at what it had
hoped to be its next host well let's
just say the tragedy frown carved into
its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate it wasn't holding the mask
it was holding a life-size cardboard
cutout of a photo of the Mask grinning
out from one side enrage the possessive
Mass tore the decoy in half with its
mannequin's hands Hey Pachuco said a
cartoonish voice from right behind it
did you miss me the mask had reappeared
for real this time grinning with his
huge teeth clearly getting a kick out of
having someone to torment
scp-035 on the other hand had been
getting increasingly irritated by all
the wacky cartoon Antics with all the
aggression it could Channel through its
mannequin host he'd grip the mask by the
throat his eyes bulging out of his head
again
need to get all choked up over it he
gagged you are so tiresome the
possessive mask yelled having finally
run out of patience you know what I
won't merge with you I should just kill
you and put an end to your buffoonery
let me take this thing off you first
though its mannequin fingers started to
hook into the mask's seam at the back of
his bald green head wait wait the mask
bag putting up both his hands and
surrender at least give me a final
request huh Master mask before the
possessive mask could respond the mask
had swept it off its dissolving
mannequin feet he started to spin it
around in a wild over the top dance
number bopping and Swinging to a tune
that seemed to be coming from nowhere
the longer it went on for the more and
more of scp-035's host's body started to
dissolve away until the mannequin
finally wasted away all that was left
was a bubbling pile of black goo on the
ground with the possessive mask laying
in the middle The Mask chuckled noticing
the fumes trailing upwards into the air
as the corrosive substance melted away
the last of
scp-035's host talk about smoking so
here's a statement that won't blow
anyone's mind the SCP Foundation is
really really really weird and we're not
even talking about the actual anomalies
they contain sure this top secret
organization puts in the time and the
effort to make sure menaces to society
like the hard to destroy reptile the
Scarlet King and even the horrifying bad
joke Tomatoes stay behind lock and key
but sometimes you need to hold the
mirror up to yourself and see just what
the heck is going on I mean seriously
think about it this is an organization
that uses live human beings farmed from
Death Row as test subjects considering
how rarely the death penalty is actually
employed in the Western World these days
you know some shady strings are being
pulled there and what about the o5
council the leaders of Humanity's last
line of defense against anomalous chaos
and according to some accounts they're a
group of vain Petty and morally bankrupt
individual tools who regularly use
anomalies like scp-006 the Fountain of
Youth for their own personal benefit and
don't even get me started on the actual
scientists working under the
foundation's payroll that's when things
start getting even stranger of course
there's Dr Jack Bright a man forever
changed by the chance interaction with
scp-963 an anomalous Medallion and one
of Abel's deadly blades now he's an
immortal weirdo who's equal parts
brilliant and a total nuisance so much
so that there's an entire dedicated list
for bidding all of his Xenia Antics then
there's Dr alto clef don't even try to
shake his hand given how much this
ex-goc wildcard loves using violence to
solve his problems you may draw back a
stump he specializes in reality warping
anomalies often wields a ukulele because
he's just so darn quirky oh and he's
very likely the baby daddy to a teenage
nature Sprite after a deliance with a
goddess or oh and um what about Dr
Charles Ogden gears sure he may not look
that straight range to the naked eye
he's a man so dull and humorous that
gray is his favorite color and he thinks
sugar on corn flakes is an act of
unacceptable decadence but he's got a
whole lot of strangeness under the hood
like the fact he's such an emotionally
unavailable father that his daughters
across Dimensions have formed a Splinter
Cell of the Serpent's hand where they
work under the collective pseudonym The
Black Queen just to spite him Dr Dan
threw acts of sabotage was personally
responsible for the worst scp-096
outbreak in Foundation history leading
to the end of thousands of lives just so
he could receive clearance to terminate
the creature and he got that clearance
on the condition that the SCP Foundation
would be terminating him for his crimes
as soon as the goal is achieved and then
there's oh my gosh did someone dress a
dog up and signed his clothes
oh my God that's the cutest thing I've
ever seen oh this is just brighten my
day okay maybe I was being too harsh on
the foundation before whose dog is this
excuse me sir that is extremely
inappropriate wait you can talk of
course I can talk you told I'm Professor
Kane pathos Crow one of the SCP
foundation's finest Minds in the field
of advanced Robotics and biochemistry I
have a level 4 clearance for 343's sake
I'm not some common bloody mutt oh my
apologies Professor Crow I wasn't aware
you were a well a talking dog well yes I
imagine there's a lot you don't know
about me isn't there
um I'm a little embarrassed to admit it
but uh that's true Professor Crowe our
data on you and your work with the SCP
Foundation is a little sparse yeah take
these files they should give you a good
primer okay I suppose we better take
this from the top then Professor Kane
pathos Crow among a lineup of extremely
eccentric researchers somehow manages to
ride to the very top in terms of sheer
strangeness to get the most obvious fact
out of the way yes while he was once a
human an anomalous experiment did result
in him being turned into a Labrador
Retriever out of this happen you may ask
we have the same question sadly
Professor Crowe is incredibly reluctant
to share any details about this strange
and embarrassing incident so we're just
gonna have to accept it for what it is
and move on everyone ready
okay good despite his strange appearance
Professor Crow is actually one of the
more scientifically qualified of the
foundation researchers it's no surprise
that because of this he has a relatively
close working relationship with Dr gears
so much so that he still refers to gears
by his early Foundation code name Cog a
reference to both the legendary Stern
doctor's initials and a pun on his
iconic surname during one incident Dr
gears did tell Professor Crowe to
terminate an anomaly that was for all
intents and purposes a human child if it
presented any difficulties this souers
the wholesomeness of that previous facto
will swiftly move on once again Dr gears
is just terrible with kids like a lot of
foundation researchers Professor Crowe
was personally head hunted by the SCP
Foundation after his academic work in
the fields of advanced Robotics and
biochemistry started Turning Heads This
was just for clarity's sake back before
Professor Crowe was turned into a
labrador Professor Crowe spends most of
his time working in biorech area 12
where he studies a variety of anomalies
but his bookish nature also earned him
another interesting position he's the
SCP foundation's Chief librarian where
his encyclopedic knowledge of anomalous
technical literature has made him a
valuable asset in archiving and
organization this balances out some of
Professor Crow's indiscretions it is
important to specify that Professor
Crowe is genuinely a well-liked figure
among his SCP Foundation co-workers
after all who wouldn't love to work with
an adorable dog in a lab coat and
glasses all day but it's also important
to note that he is also somewhat
mistaken prone with a number of these
mistakes putting him in the crosshairs
of his superiors Professor Crowe has
come close to outright termination
several times perhaps the most out of
any prominent researcher currently
working at the foundation however to
keep himself out of the same Dead Man
Walking category that the thoroughly
unpleasant Dr Dan currently finds
himself in Professor Crowe has a few
aces up his sleeve first firstly he's
got friends in the administrative
Department willing to pull a few strings
to keep him out of Harm's Way hey maybe
they're just very Ardent dog lovers up
there the other thing that's kept him
from being turned into an extremely
overqualified chew toy for scp-682 is
the content of His Brilliant brain on
many of the occasions where the o5
council have considered terminating him
he's demonstrated the fact he possesses
vital and often Irreplaceable knowledge
saving his furry skin a perfect example
of the kinds of strange scrapes that
Professor Crow gets himself into is the
incident in 2009 where without even
realizing it he somehow traveled through
time and scared The Living Daylights out
of everyone the details are best
expressed here in Professor Crow's own
dictated notes 1802 2009 in all my years
working here there have been few things
which have irritated me cause me
physical harm yes Cosby undue stress yes
cause me innumerable amount of mental
distress yes but few things have just
irritated
time travel is one of them I went to bed
on the 15th of January year 2009 at 1 30
a.m I woke up on February 18th at 9 26
a.m of the same year I hadn't moved I
had only nine hours of sleep and to me
nothing had happened then after a
slightly confused day amidst the many
cries of I thought you were dead among
other things I might add I discovered
that I have been missing for the past
month and three days in that time Sophia
had completely taken over my duties
though she had halted all of my personal
experiments and was trying her utmost to
relocate me while keeping my
disappearance from the higher-ups
Apparently data expunged leaving me to
sleep in a small self-contained bubble
of Taylor expunged and making at least
two expunged which was eventually
eruptured by do not expunged and sending
me back to this phase of space and time
needless to say I was slightly irritated
to say the least
2402 2009 it had me quarantine for
nearly the past week observing me and
running tests to see if they can find
any sort of strange abnormalities with
my physiology my behavior my anything if
I had one more hand shoved up my nether
regions or I'm forced to look at one
more bloody Inked blood I'm going to
flip out and go rabbit I'll say they'll
stop the quarantine soon and Sophia says
the higher ups still haven't caught onto
anything I suppose I'm lucky in that
count normally the only time they
quarantine something is when it's too
dead to be any sort of immediate
security Hazard still I guess I can see
where they're coming from if it were my
decision I'd probably force a quarantine
2 and probably for longer at least they
had the decency to give me my clothes my
PDA and someone to dictate to 1203 2009
I'm still here and I hate it day in day
out it's the same thing get up eat
exercise then simple observation until
lunch then more observation until dinner
then lights out not allowed anything
other than the things I already have and
even then I only got those because
Sophia felt bad me I'm only allowed to
use them every day for an hour at most
otherwise they're also in observational
storage all this wasted time that I
could have been doing something
constructive something useful something
interesting but no I'm stuck here
because of a right twist of fate forcing
me into this monotonous hell they keep
telling me I'll be let out soon Liars
0.505 2009 they've seen fit to release
me I almost thought I was going to die
in there still it almost seems strange
to be out and about again but I do
appreciate being back in my own quarters
my own clothes and my beloved walk are
back by my side Sophia has taken good
care of the facility while I was gone I
think I might actually leave that to her
when I keep to my experiments she seems
to enjoy the great deal suits her
analytical mind
all of my personal experiments are still
waiting for me with the exception of the
040 test logs they simply haven't posted
their findings yet stating that they
needed my approval first so I'll have to
pour through those the first chance I
get I'm interested in the progress she
may have made still there is a good deal
of work to be done more than ready
enough to take it on after all I have to
make up for lost time don't I it's clear
that life isn't easy for poor Professor
Crow much like Dr bright After
experiencing the mysterious event that
turned him into a dog Professor Crow is
both a researcher and an anomaly and
unlike the superficially subtle
presentation of Dr Bright's anomalous
nature it's hard to hide the strangeness
of a talking dog in human clothes this
bizarre interstatial Zone he occupies
forces the foundation to keep him on an
extremely short leash no pun intended
seriously Professor it wasn't intended I
swear anyway the point is Professor
Crowe isn't allowed to clock off at the
end of the work day like his fellow
researchers do he's forced to remain on
site almost never appearing in public if
the professor wasn't the kind of person
who could easily get lost in his work a
situation like this would probably drive
him insane speaking of you're probably
wondering by this point other than being
the cutest researcher at the foundation
sorry Dr clef you're special in your own
way we promise what kind of work is
Professor Kane pathos Crow actually
known for around here Professor Crowe's
most notable body of work is largely
based on an opinion that's pretty
controversial to hold around the SCP
Foundation he believes that they should
be actively utilizing anomalies that
aren't dangerous in order to further
their Collective goals an excellent
example of this is The Cordial
relationship he has with scp-040 also
known as Evolution's child choose a
powerful reality warper who is able to
synthesize new anomalous life from
pre-existing living creatures Professor
Crowe who refers to her as Emma in his
personal writings was initially training
her to do this with scp-148 the infamous
telekil alloy however he also filed a
formal request to go further saying I
think it's about time we started trying
to utilize 040's abilities or at the
very least allowing her to use them
enough to actually learn how to control
them she will not be able to rely on the
scp-140 headpieces forever we theorize
that as she gets older her powers will
increase exponentially possibly to the
point where her unconscious telepathy
cannot be contained he also somewhat
infamously went hammed with a series of
experiments using scp-158 a frightening
anomalous device known as the soul
extractor which contrary to its name
Professor Crowe also realized could
place removed Souls into other objects
or creatures this led to the creation of
a being that Crow dubbed zero because it
was subject zero in his experiments to
create a composite Soul using scp-158 he
spoke of this subject somewhat creepily
in his notes zero would make an
excellent candidate for my assistant it
respects and admires me for its creation
much as a child would and endearing
father figure I have assured it that it
would be treated well and that I would
give it a host to the best of my ability
to create all that it asks of me is that
it be given a name other than zero a
name not a number I told it to give
itself a name to Christen itself
whatever it so wishes he told me it
would have to think about it like a lot
of strange and fascinating figures
everything you learn about Professor
Kane pathos Crow seems to raise new
questions is Crow just a mad scientist
Without a Cause eager to perform bizarre
experiments for their own sake well not
quite the sum total of all of Professor
Crow's work is Project Olympia a topic
that probably deserves a whole video in
its own right and do sound off in the
comments if you'd like to hear more
about the deranged Frankenstein Project
that Professor Crowe has devoted his
life to you see project Olympia is
Crow's baby and also his attempt to play
God through combining a variety of
different anomalies including all the
ones we've mentioned here and several
others he would hope to create an
entirely artificial living thing that
would serve the interests of the SCP
Foundation how exactly this would be
beneficial to the SCP Foundation is
admittedly a little confusing but seeing
this goal through to its conclusion has
become an all-consuming obsession for
Professor Crowe he's performed countless
experiments with a huge catalog of
anomalies under the project Olympia
umbrella he's written Reams upon reams
of notes and logs on the subject and
produced a huge number of prototypes
he's also used project Olympia as a
pretense to remove even more Souls using
scp-158 because that just appears to be
a strange obsession of his doesn't it
incidentally we aren't the only ones
confused about the exact purpose and
value of project Olympia when members of
the o5 council finally got a proper look
at Professor Crow's work with the
project they released the following
statement all activity related to
project Olympia has been discontinued
OverWatch command has deemed it to be a
gross waste of resources and permanently
remove support for the project with
Personnel assigned to work with it being
moved to Alternative sites a hearing is
to be held with the project
administrators to determine how the
project was able to continue as long as
it did despite the lack of any concrete
results prototypes and other equipment
have been slated to be decommissioned
Professor Crowe took this news about as
well as you could expect but in the end
he always finds a way to wriggle out and
continue doing whatever he wants to do
because that's what Professor Kane
pathos Crow is all about he's living
proof that sometimes you just can't keep
a good dog down boom on May 12 25 88 the
town of kangastok Greenland was
destroyed by a devastating four kiloton
explosion accompanied by a massive
electromagnetic pulse the few survivors
that made it through the incident alive
described seeing a pale green light in
the area at the time of the explosion
shortly after an mka class scenario or
end of death scenario began in which all
multicellular life on Earth began to
experience a regenerative effect
regardless of injury or illness in other
words nobody could die anymore this
resulted in intense worldwide panic in
the face of the inexplicable occurrence
as the Panic mounted the open 5 Council
of the FCP Foundation held an emergency
meeting in order to address the
possibilities at hand meanwhile
civilians began reporting sightings of a
gigantic pale white humanoid monster
rampaging through their cities and
communities wrecking havoc and violently
attacking anyone and anything in its
path as the situation progressed and
worsened and the reality of the end of
death scenario began to set in the SCP
Foundation made the difficult decision
to lift its veil of secrecy and reveal
itself to the world 05-1 made a
statement to the U.N regarding the
reality of the worldwide anomaly
advising citizens to remain calm and
await further instructions five days
after the world learned the truth of the
SCP Foundation the pale monster arrived
in Saint John's Newfoundland where it
was met by mobile Task Force new 7
hammer down for what they hoped would be
a quick fight and neutralization instead
two years of devastating bloody combat
ensued by July 4 20 590 ninety percent
of the Task Force personnel had been
killed and regenerated an average of
five times at this point MTF News 7
abandoned the city of Saint John citing
anomalously poor working conditions
after being held in place for two years
the monster was able to break through
the defensive line and continue its
Rampage on October 10 2590 the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition came together in an act of
unprecedented cooperation to found
project Beluga dedicated to the goal of
neutralizing the monster designated
scp-u-bu and stopping its reign of
terror but project Beluga was unable to
neutralize the entity before it reached
Columbus Ohio on December 29 2590 once
it arrived in the city SCP ubu began
dedicating its time to a gruesome
personal project first it dug a two
kilometer deep hole in the city center
next it gathered a total of 2.9 million
civilians throwing them into the hole
after the hole was full The Entity
leaped into the upper Stratosphere over
and over again stomping into the hole
each time when the people inside were
pulverized The Entity destroyed a large
Fountain which it used as a cup and
drank the resulting juices from the hole
this entire process took roughly one
year and when it was finished the entity
appeared to grow bored with Columbus and
moved to Lake Erie upon reaching Lake
Erie SCP ubu trudged out into the water
and began assaulting the cargo ship
stock there it began lifting ships up
and throwing them out of the water some
flying high enough to exit Earth's
gravitational pole altogether two of the
ships were later spotted on the surface
of the Moon this chaos and destruction
continued for years and years until June
10 2670 when SCP ubu was contained at
SCP Foundation site 59 however this
containment only lasted did for two
minutes at which point The Entity
escaped and made its way to New York
City where it was found howling and
attempted to defile the Statue of
Liberty several countries used their
nuclear arsenals to attack SCP ubu over
the course of its Rampage until this
Connecticut agreement was signed on
February 10 2674 cementing an agreement
between NATO Powers the Russian
Federation the People's Republic of
China and the global occult Coalition
all signatories agree that due to the
concerns around the environment any
additional nuclear strikes against the
entity would be prohibited after the
signing was finished SCP ubu crashed the
ceremony grabbing several lengths of
rebar and 15 foreign dignitaries which
it used to construct itself a b necklace
the next notable incident occurred when
SCP ubu showed up at site 19
interrupting a round of testing with SCP
AFF a woman capable of turning matter
into stone by speaking to it SCP ubu
broke through ceiling crushing AFF
beneath its weight
scp-682 which was also present
approached the entity curiously and SCP
ubu responded by angrily defecating and
shouting at scp-682 in gibberish
scp-682 seemed to understand this
vocalization and attacked scp-ubu
demanding that it take back the insult
at this point SCP UVU slapped 682's
cheek causing 682 to let out a horrific
screen the slap left behind a glowing
green Mark which spread over the entity
of 682's body before breaking the bonds
of its cells all at once dissolving the
reptile into a pool of toxic fluid SCP
ubu then spent five minutes bathing in
this fluid while giggling after
finishing its bath devouring the
reconstituted scp-aff and screaming into
the microphone for 20 minutes SCP ubu
broke into armed containment area 179
and swallowed
scp-2317 hole on March 5th 2686 SCP ubu
conducted an assault on thumbnail class
scp-2000 rendering it neutralized again
years of Hell passed as project Beluga
struggled to come up with new methods
that had not already been exhausted
meanwhile civilians did their best to
find ways to cope with the state of the
world on March 25th 2750 former film
star Nash Degroot published the Zonk
Manifesto A book based around a simple
principle life on Earth was no longer
worth living consciously and the only
way formed was to enter an eternal coma
through the combination of chemicals and
guided meditation this kick-started the
social movement the international Zonk
on June 24 2790 project Beluga forces
managed to drive scp-ubu into the Bay of
Bengal where it remained for three years
causing very little trouble aside from
underwater seismic events meanwhile the
international Zonk continued to grow and
one massive adherence known as cuddle
reached its goal of 5 million residents
on June 10 2793 SCP ubu flung
scp-3000 out of the ocean leaving it
beached on the soil of India several
cities were destroyed in this process
The Entity then spent a week pointing
and laughing at The Beached sea monster
before grabbing it by the tip of its
tail and beginning to drag it across
Asia SCP ubu continued carving a path
through Asia the wriggling scp-3000 in
tow until it reached the Bering Strait
then it began to cross the strait into
Alaska returning to North American
territory once more but it didn't stop
there instead advancing towards South
America until it and scp-3000 arrived on
the eastern coast of Brazil on August 29
2793 there it dragged its unfortunate
charge back into the ocean once more
disappearing from sight on August 30th
scp-169 or the Leviathan emerge from the
depths of the ocean there are some
reports that scp-3000 had been tied
around its neck but these have not been
confirmed the Leviathan and SCP ubu then
entered into a lengthy battle which
carried on for several hundred years
after so much time had passed that
Witnesses could scarcely remember a time
when it wasn't happening the fight
between scp-ubu and scp-169 came to a
halt much as it had with scp-682 SCP ubu
slapped scp-169 across the face with
such force that its cell bonds dissolved
and it melted into a puddle of fluid
which was lost beneath the ocean waves
scp-169 was reclassified neutralized
December 11 3020 marked the start of a
10-year period of inactivity for scp-ubu
ordinarily one would expect this to come
with a sense of relief however even in
spite of the global immortality the
collateral damage from SCP ubu's Center
trees of Carnage had rendered the
surface of the Earth uninhabitable with
all land now underwater the remains of
human civilization persist on a single
archipelago of floating cities
constructed from ships and debris
meanwhile the international Zonk
movement has persisted gaining more and
more traction and popularity as
conscious life became less and less
bearable an enormous floating Zonk pile
consisting of international Zonk
followers using anomalous methods to
achieve the perfect Zonk began to form
eventually this pile earned the nickname
new zonkland by May 28 3028 the
archipelago was abandoned and the 140
remaining conscious humans were treated
to the SCP foundation's scps Naismith
there they lived in relative safety for
several months until SCP ubu was spotted
in the water off the port bow of the
naysmith on January 14 3030. it emitted
several sounds that Witnesses described
as mocking before swimming off towards
new zonklin in response to this
reappearance after 10 years of
inactivity the o5 council called an
emergency meeting the transcript for
this meeting reads as follows we haven't
exhausted all of our anomalous options
for neutralizing ubu where's the Corn
Creek we've been over since Florence
is only going to it just anchored 57
clicks to Southeast for why the hell did
you tell him that well friends it seems
the Omega K has had us up in about so
long that our personalities have run out
of fuel we were given from birth in all
likelihood we'd see better
professionalism and teamwork in new
zonkland as a matter of fact that's a
good segue into what I was about to
propose and frankly I hope you find the
nicest cleanest spots in the mass grave
where are you going that depends which
way is southeast at this point o5-11
left the room presumably to track down
the Corn Creek leaving the remains of
the o5 council there and leaving the
remains of project Beluga with the
question of how to handle
scp-u-b-u according to its official SCP
Foundation file SCP ubu is an extremely
violent and hostile humanoid entity of
Unknown Origin which appeared in
Greenland on May 12 2588 it displays
anomalous physical strength and speed as
well as reality bending capabilities and
the emission of regenerative Lambda
waves linked to the ongoing end of death
scenario the appearance of SCP ubu and
the start of the end of death scenario
coincided with several additional
phenomenon there was a mass loss of
function for all the objects operated by
the three moons initiative the three
moons initiative was an extra
dimensional human organization based in
scp-2922-c or the afterlife known as
corbenek this organization was founded
14 000 years ago with the purpose of
establishing a human colony in the
afterlife it has long maintained a peace
treaty with the SCP Foundation
scp-2922 a method of community education
that allowed a human mind to make calls
to any pre-established phone number
ceased all functions next the extra
dimensional space known as The Wanderers
Library a magical Archive of all the
knowledge from all known worlds and
every book that has ever been written
will be written and several that have
not and will not exist was severed from
Earth when the SCP Foundation pressed
the Serpent's hand for answers a
representative answered that
irreconcilable security concerns
regarding Earth had come up and forced
them to make this decision a
representative of Marshall Carter and
dark limited somehow gained access to
the personal contact information of the
o5 council's members and use this
information to reach out to them with a
business offer the company is ordinarily
on unfriendly terms with the SCP
Foundation due to their conflicting
interests namely Marshall Carter and
dark's interests in acquiring and
selling anomalous items entities and
experiences to the highest bidder
however in this case the company's
representative have approached o5
council members with a mixture of
politeness and Desperation begging the
SCP Foundation to purchase large amounts
of the company's stock the forest known
as scp-4000 lost all of its anomalous
properties all at once investigation
revealed only a small parchment note in
the area's entryway which read good luck
one of the most perplexing and
disconcerting phenomenon that occurred
concurrently with SCP ubu's first
appearance was what happened to scp-3008
the infinite Ikea though this sort of
thing should have been impossible the
infinite Ikea was anomalously purchased
by some unknown entity the Ikea branding
was stricken from the building and it
was converted into an emergency shelter
all of these occurrences combine to
serve as a warning something big is
coming and indeed it was
scp-u-b-u it appears to be impervious to
most forms of damage including blunt
force trauma heavy caliber machine gun
fire temperatures up to 16 800 degrees
Kelvin artillery fire and Direct Energy
discharge from other anomalies it did
express some discomfort when exposed to
severe simultaneous direct nuclear
strikes but it was not affected beyond
that they only recorded instance of
lasting damage to SCP ubu was on August
14 2784 in which the entity bit its left
thumb seemingly for no reason other than
curiosity after biting its thumb The
Entity screened for seven days straight
then entered into a month-long crying
fit 30 years and 14 days later the thumb
had completely healed SCP ubu stands at
a height of 4.3 meters one exact measure
of its weight is unknown attempts at
measurement during its brief time and
containment showed that its weight is at
least 15 399 kilograms its exact
anatomical composition is unknown but a
superficial examination of the entity
indicates that its body shape resembles
that of a large androgynous humanoid
covered in hairless white skin similar
in texture to that of a dolphin or small
whale The Entity has no eyes ears or
nostrils but seems to still possess the
ability to see hear and smell its only
visible sensory organ aside from its
skin is its 0.5 meter wide mouth
humanoid in nature with a prehensile
tongue of unknown length on its lower
body it has no apparent features aside
from a colaweka that it uses to dispose
of waste SCP ubu is prone to
vocalizations mainly screaming laughing
and babbling but it does not appear to
understand speech in any known language
nor does it seem to be attempting to
communicate with anyone it encounters
its primary interest appears to be
destruction and causing as much of it as
possible it will attack anything that it
can get its hands on but seems to show a
particular preference for attacking and
consuming human beings in large populous
areas such as cities its demeanor is
both sadistic and childlike and it has
been seen playing with its victims for
hours before moving on to a new Target
due to its regenerative effect present
in SCP ubu's vicinity it is incapable of
causing permanent damage to any living
thing and seems to have no greater
motivation Beyond causing fear and pain
SCP ubu is classified as Tiamat meaning
that it cannot be reasonably contained
at this time with the resources that the
foundation has therefore the focus has
shifted from containment to
neutralization which is ongoing via
project Beluga any and all non-critical
resources will be funneled into project
Beluga as neutralization of SCP ubu is a
top priority additional information on
neutralization efforts is restricted and
may only be accessed by members of
project Beluga but in the end it won't
be project Beluga that defeats this
monstrous creature it'll be the staunch
efforts of one extremely dedicated
researcher obviously it helps to be an
animal lover when you start working at a
shelter it's not exactly a requirement
of the job but it definitely makes it a
little more palatable when you
occasionally have to deal with a critter
that's more nasty than usual having an
already built in compassion towards
animals makes it easier to forgive them
for not doing what you want from a very
young age Harper always liked to think
of animals as people they just didn't
think or communicate the same way as
humans even the best trained pets in the
world don't really know the actual
meaning of certain words they're just
taught how to respond to specific
commands in certain ways but that
doesn't mean they couldn't also have
distinct personalities of their own just
like humans do and then of course there
were all the wild animals that had never
been trained or domesticated Harper
always felt a little sorry for any baby
bird with its wing broken or any badgers
or possum that arrived at the shelter
after getting hit by a car they didn't
live around humans and had probably
never even experience being indoors
before let alone having people nursing
them back to health to empathize Harper
used to imagine how terrified she would
be if she was hurt if she'd broken her
leg or arm or Worse only for something
much larger than her to take her into a
structure she'd never been in before and
on top of that having no way of
understanding that this giant was trying
to help her heal as well as being
separated from her friends family and
everyone she knew the way she saw it
this was what it must have been like for
the majority of animals that were
brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patients he gotta fortify your heart in
this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold and heartless
that would be an over correction but it
was there and Harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate Medical Care
and provide a temporary sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
but Harper had to remember was that none
of them were her own pets often a lot of
the critters that were brought into the
shelter were already someone else's
companion and might have just got lost
while out on a walk and while some
others were given up by their previous
owners who had cruelly Shrugged off the
responsibility of caring for them those
animals were in need of new homes and
couldn't stay cooped up in the shelter
forever not everyone that gave up their
pet did it callously though sometimes
they might have found themselves falling
on hard times and being unable to
financially look after an animal others
might have owned a pet that had a
behavioral problem like being too
aggressive and even though the person
still loved them dearly they might have
just not been able to make it work in
times like that they'd have no choice
but to take their animal to the shelter
just outside the side entrance was an
area where people could drop off their
animals and quickly Buzz to the staff
inside just in case they wanted to avoid
a protracted emotional farewell to their
four-legged or winged companion the
buzzer had sounded just as Harper had
been coming off for lunch break it was
her turn this shift to quickly go and
collect any animal that had been left
out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cage or with
their lead tied to a nearby Street Lamp
Harper knew she had to rush to the side
door just in case somebody else tried to
rush in and steal the poor abandoned pet
after turning them in the lock she
hooked her keys back on the belt clip
she wore and pushed the side door open
Harper had been fully expecting to see
the usual a leash dog or cat coming over
to investigate her confused as to where
their former owner had gone this time
though there was just a box standing
outside it wasn't huge in fact it was
almost entirely empty almost picking it
up carefully in case there were baby
birds or a nests have unhatched eggs
inside Harper opened the cardboard flap
to reveal a rock sitting in the Box was
a single solitary Rock an oval of smooth
Granite with a paper note next to it
reaching in she retrieved and unfolded
the scrap please care for my pet rock
was written on one side in a messy
uncoordinated scroll immediately
assuming that this whole thing was some
kids idea of a joke Harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabies and
a squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended Harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave she
headed through the side door mainly so
that she could do a final check in case
any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and Harper
hooked her bag over her shoulder
shutting the the door behind her
something the size and weight of a
baseball knocked against her foot
causing her to look down and see the
rock the same one from earlier only now
it had flipped over probably after she
had tipped it out of its box on the side
facing up at her the rock had a shiny
metal zipper fastened shut curious
Harper picked it up to take a closer
look it didn't seem like the zip had
just been glued onto the Stone's surface
it was embedded in it actually part of
the rock itself and there was something
sad about it sure it was just a rock an
inanimate lump of stone but for whatever
reason a feeling of pity crept up on
Harper causing her to slip the rock into
her bag as she headed for the parking
lot it was starting to get dark by the
time she got home heading up to her room
and flipping on her lamp Harper placed
the zipped up Stone under its light and
took another long look at it although
she'd first thought it was purely a joke
now she couldn't tell if it was some
elaborate art piece or a quirky Garden
ornament the thing was solid Stone all
the way through surely the Zipper was
just for show there couldn't possibly be
anything beneath it to her surprise the
metal Fastener began to part as Harper
dragged on the puller and slider down
from the top stop towards the bottom one
it was relatively easy not even some of
her own clothes unzipped as smoothly as
this rock as soon as the slider
connected with the bottom stop the teeth
of the top and bottom edges parted
revealing more teeth below except these
almost looked like human teeth they
opened up to reveal a mouth a part of
the rock just like the zipper which took
the place of its lips the moment the
mouth opened let out a tiny sound like
it was breathing which startled Harper
with a Yelp she dropped the Rock from
her hands and it even made a tiny grunt
as it fell to the floor it was alive
seeing it hit her bedroom carpet her
Harper stared utterly bewildered at the
Rock its toothy mouth almost looks sad
like it had curved into a frown then she
heard the sound it was making perhaps it
was her years working with animals at
the shelter and her long-held sympathy
for them that had given her a sort of
protective Instinct for all living
things or maybe it was just the
bizarreness of the situation of having a
rock with a mouth whimpering in pain on
the floor in front of her either way
Harper felt compelled to pick the lump
of stone back up and place it gently on
the desk its mouth seemed to smile a bit
more as she did while it seemed creepy
at first the compulsion to take care of
this helpless Little Rock only got
stronger grabbing a pipette and pouring
a glass of water from the faucet Harper
started to squeeze out droplets of water
into the Rock's mouth she had no idea
how it was able to drink but that didn't
seem at all important or relevant in
order for her to care for it after all
every time a parrot or duck or Crow was
brought into the state Nation the
procedure was similar Harper would have
to pipette them water or medicine it
didn't matter how they drank it just
because they had beaks it was the same
with baby animals puppies and kittens
especially who might need bottle feeding
if there were only a few weeks old as
much as she was starting from scratch
and would normally be completely baffled
as to the best ways she could care for
the Rock right now Harper was pulling on
her experience at the shelter to nurse
it back to health if she was in fact
using her instincts and not being
influenced somehow over the next few
days Harper looked after her Newfound
patient as if it had been her lifelong
pet as to why she was taking such care
of a rock or even what she would
eventually do with it Harper didn't
really have much of a clue but the
answer to those questions didn't feel as
important as looking after the rock
she'd leave for work in the morning only
to count down the hours through her
shift until she got to go home and tend
to The Smiling Stone throughout the
course of her working day she would
pocket supplies to help her take better
care of her new pet everything from
medicine in case it got sick or picked
up an infection of some kind two
bandages and other materials she could
use as bedding grabbing a fresh clean
plastic container for it instead of
another cardboard box Harper was
gradually fashioning a nest for the
toothy Pebble and for the most part it
seemed to be working some deep-seated
feeling told her that her efforts to
look after the rock was gradually making
it feel better every day and then it
started talking it wasn't exactly
articulate or eloquent it didn't even
seem to know that many words other than
the two it was weakly repeating when she
came home from work one day
it rasped a horse whisper passing
through his unzipped lips rushing over
to it barely questioning it Harper tried
filling up her pipette and giving it
more water The Rock spat it back out
before speaking again no drink only eat
what what do I need to feed you she
asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice or
could her compelling need to care for it
make her oblivious to the strangeness of
this situation of course this wasn't a
situation that many people had also
found themselves in this meant that even
a quick cursory internet search for what
do pet rocks eat didn't yield many
useful results only a few joke articles
and nothing that actually gave Harper an
answer she could act on all the while
her Rock was still croaking out the same
two words repeating them on a loop its
little voice getting more and more
forceful each time
low on options Harper left some bread
crusts in The Rock's Nest hoping that
would be enough to at least satiate the
Rock's obvious hunger it paused either
smelling or sensing that it had been
offered something to eat
it rafts before opening its mouth wide
with a tiny expectant
picking up the crusts one by one Harper
broke little pieces often fed each bit
to a rock she sighed as a sense of
overwhelming relief came flooding over
her glad that she'd found a way to feed
the mouthy little mineral if only it had
worked for longer only a few hours later
Harper was met with more scraping
demands from her pet rock the insistent
sound waking her up in the middle of the
night but this time as she offered it
more bread scraps it refused to eat them
it was still the early hours of the
morning by the time that Harper had
gotten through offering the rock every
different type of food in her kitchen
eventually giving up through sheer
exhaustion she folded her pillow over
her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of
eight but it didn't do enough to allow
her to get to sleep at any rate the
feeling that she had to care for this
talking Rock was keeping her awake as
much as the noise staring across the
room purposely facing away from her pet
rock Harper's eyes fell over her work
uniform the logo of the animal shelter
stitched on it was just about visible as
the gentle glow of Street lamps bled
through the curtains and seeing it along
with her keys clipped onto her belt that
lay on the floor gave her an idea that
might work desperation and the need to
sleep getting the better of her Harper
climbed in the car having put a jacket
and jeans over her pajamas the streets
were all empty at this hour almost pitch
dark and deathly silent but a maid
driving from her home to her workplace a
lot faster than usual all the while The
Rock's voice was getting more and more
demanding from its container that she
had strapped to the front passenger seat
sneaking up to the side door Harper
turned her key in the lock pulled it
open
slipped indoors the moment they heard
the sound of the door shutting a number
of the dogs that had been resting
securely in their cages woke up and
started barking the noise loudly echoing
around the shelter even though it
drowned Out The Rock's tiny voice it
felt as if its words were still ringing
in Harper's ears compelling her to go
through with something she really didn't
want to and yet it felt like one of the
only other options she had left she
decided it would have to be the squirrel
rationalizing the choice in her head in
an unpleasant but purely calculated
logic-based way it made the most sense
earlier that week the bushy-tailed
Woodland forager had been hit by a moped
it had barely survived given the number
of its tiny bones that had been broken
in the force of the impact fighting its
cage it was still asleep heavily sedated
on the dosage of painkillers the
shelter's resident vet had given it
gently scooping it out of the cage
feeling its fur against her cupped hand
Harper looked at her pet rock its
container on table she remembered that
it liked to be fed directly swallowing
an urge to be sick that was rising at
the back of her throat Harper opened a
drawer in the vet's office and pulled
out a surgical scalpel when her boss at
the shelter heard there had been a
break-in and reviewed the footage on the
building's security cameras they were
shocked at what they saw though the
angle obscured what Harper was doing the
blood left over and one missing squirrel
seemed to be enough to go on that
coupled with the fact that she had
broken in after hours and the numerous
supplies that had gone missing from the
storage cupboard led to Harper being
dismissed she was fired from her job at
the animal shelter forced to hand over
her keys in uniform while any other day
this would have devastated her the
events seemed to wash over Harper pretty
quickly she was more relieved now
pleased with herself that The Rock had
stopped begging her to be fed her plan
had worked for now it took about a week
for her pet rock to start demanding food
again this time just the sound of its
voice made Harper
any ordinary human food she offered
wasn't enough it didn't want that she
already knew exactly what it wanted the
only thing she'd fetted that had
sustained it the big problem was that
now she didn't have her keys it would be
near impossible for her to get into the
shelter again yet still the forceful
command to be fed kept up day and night
hour after hour until Harper considered
the only thing she had left to give her
pet rock lifting it out of the warm Nest
she kept it in her fingers were gripping
the smooth Stone tightly her arm was
tense in fact both were one of her
muscles strained while she held the rock
the other in anticipation hovering it
above her opposite arm Harper could feel
the tiny breaths of her pet against her
skin almost like it was so excited to
eat again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quickly running into the bathroom
it wasn't that she had changed her mind
she couldn't all she knew was that had
to feed her pet rock Harper just needed
to grab a cloth to put it in her mouth
clamping her Jaws down on it to muffle
her scream as she let the Rock's teeth
sink into her Flesh Blood trickling down
her arm nobody saw much of Harbor
afterwards her friends from the shelter
would continuously call her cell phone
only to get no reply she barely paid in
the attention to the ringing eventually
just letting her phone batteries die and
not even bothering to charge it back up
it wasn't important to her the only
thing that mattered was caring for her
pet rock in Harper's head it needed to
be kept safe and fed and it was her job
to look after it to the best of her
ability she had enough left over her
medical supplies that she'd lifted from
the shelter bandages antiseptic spray
rubbing alcohol tranquilizers to treat
her wounds after a while it almost
stopped hurting knowing that she was
helping keep her pet rock fed being so
emotionally attached to it made all the
pain more bearable even when she woke up
one morning to find that her Rock had
rolled off her desk onto her bed it
hardly faced her nor did seeing that it
had gradually eaten her leg during the
night gnawing through tendons and bone
as she slept leaving her Sheets still
slick with blood when she awoke despite
having lost most of her capacity for
rational thought Harper decided it would
be best to plan ahead for when she was
gone she knew through some Twisted form
of logic that she wasn't going to last
forever there was only so much of her
she'd be able to feed her pet rock for
so long Harper held a pen in her hand as
best she could with all the fingers she
was now missing she scrawled out a note
to her ever found what was left of her
in messy uncoordinated handwriting
please care for my pet rock dozens of
Agents sprinted across the blacktop
weapons drawn they fired
indiscriminately at the building ahead
of them they only had a matter of
minutes to stop this mad Plan before it
was too late but navigating the air base
was proving to be almost impossible
banana peels littered the runway
tripping them over at nearly every step
colorful plants were springing up
through the cracks and snaring their
boots and chomping at their ankles with
rudimentary teeth somewhere high above
them a mutant reptile was throwing
hammers at their head from atop a cloud
of white gas the agents struggled and
fought their way to the hangar but it
was too late the rumbling of engines the
belch of smoke the crashing sound of a
hole being blasted through the roof they
were too late out of the smoking Hangar
Rose and Airship painted a sickening red
and composed of hunks of scrap metal the
ship was shaped like a top hat there was
a globe on the deck and a sail billowing
out of the top the door to the Airship
crashed open and out of it burst a man
with a bushy mustache denim overalls and
a red hat his eyes burned lit up with
the flame of a man with nothing to lose
he stared down at the agents below him
with a carnal Fury watching as they were
chomped crushed and blown up beneath
them but then his eyes drifted up higher
into the sky toward the prize that he
was really after the one thing that
would bring the love of his life back to
him the moon the Airship puffed out a
thick cloud of awkward smoke and shot
off into the air Rising higher and
higher as the crazed Italian growled
from its deck Circle Yahoo
let's go New York City the city that
never sleeps or rather the city where
you can never get to sleep the constant
car horns drunken yells and general
chaos of Manhattan can really get to you
especially if you live in a cheap
apartment over a convenience store Max
had been living here for the better part
of a year now and the only way he found
to unwind on the busy nights was to sit
down in front of the TV and play video
games sleep was off the table so that
was the next best thing the pipes under
his sink were busted but he couldn't be
bothered to call in a plumber he had
better things to spend his money on he'd
been desperate to buy a switch for years
but they just hadn't dropped in price in
true Nintendo fashion he was pretty sure
if he fast forwarded to the apocalypse
he still wouldn't be able to find a
switch for anything less than full price
staying up late checking out eBay
auctions he'd unbelievably actually
found one some grandma was selling it
along with all her grandson other games
according to the item description her
grandson had been hospitalized after he
broke both his hands trying to punch a
tree apparently he needed the wood to
build some kind of table anyway he'd
been banned from playing any games as a
punishment since he was getting too
obsessed with them so lo and behold a
used Nintendo switch was in Max's hands
he'd been waiting for years to play
Super Mario Odyssey after watching the
Mario movie the other day he couldn't be
more in the mood to sit down and play
supposedly one of the best games of all
time and play it Max did eyes glued to
the screen he sat there on his couch all
the way through the night Mario leaped
through the cat Kingdom with ease
stomped his dinosaur feed through the
Cascade Kingdom conquered the sand
Kingdom while jamming out to the music
and plowed on after fully exploring each
kingdom he'd hop onto his hat-shaped
Airship and fly to the next one all
Friday night he played and didn't even
realize when the sun came up on Saturday
morning he loved to see all of his
favorite characters on screen Bowser in
his white suit Cappy and all of his
spinning Glory Peach looking radiant as
usual and Sam Max racked his brains he
was trying to remember if he'd ever come
across this guy's Sam in a Mario game
before he was just some Koopa much like
any of the others except he had a white
shell every world that Mario would visit
Sam would be there somewhere often
hidden under a sphinx or behind a
waterfall it was the same dialogue
option each time whenever Mario
approached Sam a speech bubble would pop
up I want salt and meats bring them to
me hurry up but try to see Mike Max
couldn't find any items resembling salt
or Meats anywhere in the game what would
they even look like it all seemed very
out of place compared to the moons he
was supposed to be collecting it was
only once Max reached new donk City and
met Sam standing shiftily in a back
Alleyway that the dialogue changed no so
Alton Meats huh solve the food shortages
Max tried talking to him again but the
game wouldn't let him no matter what he
did he couldn't interact with Sam
anymore he searched all over New donk
City looking for anyone who could Point
him in the direction of some salt or
Meats but there was nothing none of the
other characters mentioned anything
about food shortages that was enough of
that taking his headset off Max sat back
on his couch and rubbed his eyes how
long had he been playing for long enough
to work up a real appetite planting both
hands on his knees Max pushed himself to
his feet and wandered over to the fridge
there wasn't much in there a bowl of
leftovers some cheese a few options but
nothing like what he was really craving
he pushed his way through the back and
his eyes lit up there behind everything
else was a little box he'd forgotten to
throw out the previous week mushrooms
would they still be good to eat he
didn't care taking gone off mushrooms by
the handful he shoved them into his
hungry mouth that's how he would grow
big and strong with a satisfied smile he
slammed the fridge door closed and
stared at himself in the mirror he must
have been gaming for a long time a thick
tuft of hair had appeared on his upper
lip looking this way and that Max
admired the mustache in the Morning
Light muttering under his breath Mamma
Mia
scp-3843 is a little-known bug that
appears in physical video games much
like a biological virus it is
transmitted from one copy of a game to
another through close proximity it one
game in a collection exhibits evidence
of
scp-3843's presence it likely means that
all other games in the owner's
collection also have become infected but
what is
scp-3843 well that much is currently
unclear the game's coding appears to
undergo no changes when affected and yet
a new non-player character appears when
the game is booted up how this character
manifests depends on the video game
itself but the there are a number of
consistent rules firstly the character
always fits within the world of the
video game with a small identifying
feature a white-shelf Koopa and Mario an
extra crew member on the Normandy in
Mass Effect 2 and even a diamond-shaped
block in Tetris with a hole cut out of
the middle secondly this NPC is always
identified as Sam or some variation of
that name if it is necessary to change
it to fit the world for example in Elden
ring
scp-3843 takes on the name Sam of The
Starving planes or in Pac-Man it becomes
Sammy one elusive characteristic of
these NPC characters is their obsession
with salt and meats in the majority of
incarnations any which allow the
character to have dialogue Sam always
expresses a desire to be given salt and
meats with follow-up dialogue usually
complaining of food shortages on
occasion the game will contain
additional food items that seem to be
generated by scp-3843 for example when
Sam appears as a merchant in near
automata it will sell you cubes of a
non-descript salty meat if the player
chooses to consume those items nothing
appears to happen tracking down
instances of scp-3843 has become easier
in recent years the decline of physical
game sales with the shift to a more
digital ecosystem has meant that
transmission between copies has reduced
significantly a physical disk or
cartridge is required for transmission
after all what is more Foundation
testing has revealed that this SCP is
incapable of infecting online only games
multiplayer Shooters and mobas are
totally immune to it in fact any game
that requires an internet connection to
play will be immune to transmission
while Gamers do hate the trend of having
to be online to play their single player
games there is a big upside to it from
the foundation's perspective who knows
perhaps there are agents placed in
certain publishing Studios pulling some
strings to help crack down on
scp-3843 transmission it wouldn't be the
first time the foundation has meddled
with the gaming industry to try and
control the outbreak little-known
developer Indigo games launched in 1980
to relatively small Fanfare they flew
under the radar over the three years of
their existence closing up shop in 1983
but their effect on the games industry
was enormous as they are believed to
have been the source of the original
instance of
scp-3843 with the sale of physical games
blowing up early in the 80s it was the
Prime circumstances for Sam to spread
like wildfire without much other choice
the foundation had to step in due to
large number of
scp-3843-1 instances becoming public in
1983. the foundation resorted to
emergency containment measures to
achieve this they caused a crash in the
video game Market by using their
resources to influence major players
this involved financing competing home
computer companies artificially
saturating the market using
foundation-owned companies and
undercover elements in existing
companies using Foundation elements to
encourage poor business practices in
existing game Publishers and sabotaging
upcoming projects it was a success the
gaming industry slumped and sales fell
through the floor buying enough time for
the foundation to get on top of
instances of
scp-3843 You Must Be Wondering by now
what's so bad about Sam just a harmless
NPC popping up in video games asking for
salt and meats where's the harm in that
you would be right in the context of the
game no real damage was being done the
issue came from the real World
repercussions of encountering Sam you
see when someone chooses to interact
with shopkeeper Sam start Quest Giver
Sam's storyline or engage mini boss Sam
in combat it marks the beginning of a
physiological change in the player what
this looks like depends on the game for
Zelda breath of the wild it's just a
case of the person growing blonde hair a
higher pitched voice and developing a
sudden affinity for swordsmanship puzzle
solving and hang gliding the player
undergoes physical change to make them
more closely fit into the world of the
game that they are playing while also
gaining Knowledge and Skills akin to
what their player character would
possess the first instance of this
posing a real world threat was when
Daryl McKenzie 24 was shot dead whilst
infiltrating a U.S military base after
playing an infected copy of Metal Gear
Solid before his death he had exhibited
high-level Espionage and combat
proficiency which his family all claim
he had no knowledge of prior to this
event other cases can be even more
severe such as when the player character
is not just a regular human infected
copies of cyberpunk 2077 and Deus Ex
mankind divided resulted in players
growing electronic implants in their own
bodies which most often leads to death
as their immune system rejects the
technology instances where the players
control non-human creatures are even
more severe one woman sprouted cat ears
and thick fur all over her body before
suffering multiple organ failure an
agent checking her PC found that she had
over 1 000 hours logged as a Khajiit
character in Skyrim often the foundation
is only a couple of steps behind
infected game copies and so is able to
step in and help those affected this
unfortunately was not the case with Max
three weeks passed and Max felt like he
was on top of the world he fixed the
problem under his sink no problem after
finding he suddenly had a wealth of
Plumbing knowledge somewhere in his
brain he'd gone through his entire
wardrobe and thrown out all the awful
clothes he used to wear replacing them
with much better outfits red cats denim
overalls big brown shoes it was the
perfect look for him every morning he
would sit in front of his mirror and
sculpt his mustache to Perfection
carefully trimming the hairs to the
exact right shape exploring new dunk
city was his favorite pastime he'd kick
open the door to his apartment and
stroll out onto the street looking for
Adventures every day jumping on the
roofs of taxis playing jump rope in the
park with children exploring the sewers
looking for Adventures swinging around
the flagpole on the Empire State
Building he was having a fantastic time
despite all the looks he was getting
from passersby but one thing played on
his mind the whole time Peach she was
still under Bowser's control it wasn't
fair of him to have all this fun while
the love of his life was a prisoner he
needed to collect enough moons That's
What mattered but no matter where he
looked in new donk City he just couldn't
find any the only Moon he could see was
the one sitting there in the night sky
staring out of his apartment Window
Mario Max hatched a plan his apartment
was slowly coming to life around him
little piranha plants grew out of the
pots on his windowsill he'd bought a gun
a few days ago and already the bullets
had grown little faces and arms he was
assembling a small Arsenal here enough
to take the Moon by force he heard the
pounding footsteps before the door to
the hangar flew open an agent stood
there holding a gun in trembling fingers
staring into the darkness Max let a
smile slowly creep across his face as
his gloved hand hovered over the launch
controls the agent called out into the
Shadows who's there it's me Max cranked
the lever forward and his Airship kicked
into the sky Mario gunfire rang out from
all directions as the ship Rose into the
air he cackled maniacally on the deck
watching the agents get torn apart by
all this traps they weren't going to get
in the way of him reaching his Princess
Peach not today on the ground agents
stared up as the Hat ship flew away from
them higher and higher into the sky only
the faint echo of a
drifted down to their ears before Max
ran out of oxygen and passed out on the
deck of his ship
I'm gonna be pleasing your eye you
didn't lean right up close to your
screen and open wide
bies
now hold this position for three hours
please say thank you
um
apologies that's quite enough of that
scp-001 can get a little carried away
sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen as a prime example of why
scp-001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio Ghibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water taught lace
solves crowdfunding effort had been
running for several years and that point
had gained a good deal of momentum
leading up to the release of their
latest AI construct
pallet.aic was supposedly already
prepared for launch when suddenly in
November 2022 the launch was canceled no
press release No public statement No
apologetic tweet just total radio
silence the website was taken down as
was the crowdfunding page and
palette.aic disappeared into Oblivion or
at least it disappeared for a few hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently checking
it for any hazards working in the SCP
mailroom has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 terabyte hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the top lay soft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
my daughter as best as you can for the
time being she has behavioral issues a
dedicated closed system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with scp-001 read she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 terabytes palette dot AIC as soon as
Dr Rogers opened the program an empty
window appeared the totally soft logo
briefly flashed before being replaced by
a blank white square Dr Rogers stared at
it for several seconds before glancing
over her shoulder at the other
researchers they shrunk back each with
pens hovering over clipboards ready to
take meticulous notes Dr Rogers cleared
her throat and immediately the screen
filled with life a small cartoon girl
with a pink face wide eyes a beret and a
large paintbrush for a hand appeared
squealing excitedly and throwing paint
everywhere
the entire research team promptly
scampered out of the room leaving Dr
Rogers alone in front of the machine she
stared at the Monitor and confusion
leaning this way in that and noticing
how the cartoon girl's eyes followed her
wherever she went can you see me
this perplexed most of the personnel as
there was no microphone or camera linked
up to the server rack later examinations
of the equipment used confirmed this yet
somehow this SCP was able to look right
at them Dr Rogers asked if it had a name
to which the cartoon girl excitedly
replied
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation
scp-001 read Dr Rogers had a hard time
communicating with red being a more
seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon
just like one of my human OCS gilliams
sure people's worth he's the 573rd
president of the United States Gilliam
is not that man it took several Junior
researchers a few minutes to properly
explain to Dr Rogers what an OC was and
why red was so obsessed with calling
people daddy the conversation was rather
exhausting for everyone involved but
over the subsequent hours the foundation
was able to get a fairly good
understanding of what red claimed to be
identifying itself with feminine
pronouns and claiming that its full name
is palette East River gok this AI
construct takes the appearance of a
fairy it was immediately apparent that
she possessed a greater level of
sapience than most AI constructs indeed
her gregarious personality was evidence
enough that she was not made using
standard machine learning practices
other creations from topless soft have
demonstrated very crude spelling and
grammar but red seems too different in
this regard able to spell most complex
words effectively and speaking in
conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was
we believe you palette you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight
m a c e we've heard enough can you
please just tell us how you learned to
spell
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled that the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses and interviews over the
physicality of the researchers sitting
in front of her the textures of the
human body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with Humanity that
she has mostly neglected her primary
function which is creating AI art
researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very cagey about it only showing
the occasional doodle after much
persuasion and many apologies for its
poor quality on her part the only
artwork she is interested in producing
at this point are her OCS original
characters that she has designed herself
they are all human and all seem to
reveal little quirks about how she has
been coded one example is Reginald
hedgenold frumbles who is a freelance
corporate Postman from Perth Indiana
interestingly he has too many fingers on
both of his hands but red claims that
this was done on purpose as she quote
just can't get enough of her humy's hand
worms as the weeks progress the
foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewers more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interact with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until eventually the
AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers turned on
the server rack and opened the
palette.aic program but red refused to
emerge from the bottom of the screen
only the top of her Beret poked out
after almost an hour of fruitless
questions Dr Rogers decided to change
tact with two small children of her own
she was used to seeing a child in a sulk
and knew what it would take to get them
out palette I've had a little idea
you've been here for a few months now
and we haven't gotten you any presents
almost immediately the Beret twitched I
saw that we have an old fingerprint
sensor lying around in one of the back
offices I was thinking maybe maybe we
could
[Music]
how about we start with one finger for
10 minutes
from that point on progress was quick
with the incentive of getting to study
the researchers that read kindly
referred to as her meat puppies she
became very cooperative and was able to
focus much better on providing detailed
answers to individual questions daily
interview sessions were scheduled with
researchers popping in and out to
regularly check in on the AI the
atmosphere as a whole lifted as both the
research team and research subject found
their Rhythm and were able to make good
progress in their individual areas of
study some unraveling the complexities
of Rogue Ai and others producing fan art
of her favorite wrinkles in a
scientist's fingerprint that was the
point when Dr Julian key stepped in to
conduct an interview with the AI she was
excited to be met with a fresh face so
much so that Red's enthusiasm
overwhelmed the man as he tried to start
the interview process officially she
gushed about having the opportunity to
meet yet another person and struggled to
get over the magical realization in that
this was her life every day going to
speak to all these humans whom she
admired so much trying his best to steer
the conversation towards research Dr
Keys pressed on with the interview only
to be interrupted as red noticed his
varicose veins for the first time
can I please Dr keys to climb the
request and then the conversation got
onto the topic of her Creator or Daddy
scp-2803-a had been on the foundation's
radar for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up totally soft with much of the
alien's history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an era of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
or daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest
here because he thinks you'll teach me
how to stop liking humans and become a
Mindless Arts play if you never teach me
this you'll never want me back however
she went on to slightly undermine the
good work that she had done by
explaining that her daddy was seen as
very slow and incapable by his own race
while all of his peers were able to
destroy an entire planet in two seconds
it took him about four times as long so
really he didn't pose that much of a
threat in her eyes Dr Key's blood ran
cold when we heard this no sooner was he
out of the interview chamber than an
emergency meeting was called among all
the senior researchers in the facility
the meeting ran for several hours a
whiteboard was set up where One
researcher idly Drew large drawings of
the world being decimated while the
others lounged around in their chairs
trying their best to come up with a game
plan that would save the human race for
sure perhaps it was because the meeting
ran for so long that they came to such a
ridiculous conclusion it was a plan so
strange yet also brilliant that they
couldn't help but feel that it just
might work why don't we just give her a
YouTube channel the suggestion was met
with silence for several seconds then an
uproar of laughter followed by another
silence this time more pensive as slowly
one by one each of the researchers
realized that this suggestion was
actually the best one that any of them
had come up with all evening she had
been sent to the foundation to make her
dislike humanity and become a Mindless
art slave if she just stayed in
Foundation containment indefinitely
there was a very real risk that she
would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't lock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow her to record art tutorials onto
an external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly red
absolutely loved the idea getting to
talk to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful pictures and
reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet once a week but
they argued the case that it did indeed
protect keeping her happy in a way was
helping to protect the entire planet red
was surprisingly camera shy for the
first couple of video
but as soon as she got her first batch
of comments back she was over the moon
now the server act hummed away happily
each and every day as the highly
Advanced AI construct tried her best to
come up with exciting new videos that I
could share with all of its little
humans
the SCP Foundation is home to plenty of
anomalies whose reputations precede them
here at SCP explained we've discussed
quite a few of the most notable
anomalies contained by the foundation
from the wholesome half-cats and tickle
monsters to the nightmarish giant
reptiles and reality warping old men but
there are very few anomalies so popular
so famous or inFAMOUS depending on who
you ask that they attract a Non-Stop
revolving door of would-be worshipers to
suit chaos all around the foundation
what's it like to be a creature that's
always the center of attention whether
he wants to be or not today we're taking
a look at the lifestyle of the
involuntarily famous scp-2660
E2 we took the liberty of observing a
full day in the life of the entity known
by many as Cthulhu from his morning
routine to his bedtime and all the
little moments of unplanned chaos in
between with his permission we compiled
everything we saw into a video For Your
Entertainment welcome to a day in the
life of
scp-2662 9am time to wake up stretch
your tentacles and get ready for the day
ahead at a respectable not too early and
not too late time usually around 9 A.M
but sometimes a little bit later if he's
had a particularly late night
scp-2662 climbs out of bed and uses his
computer to throw on one of his favorite
podcasts preferred topics for listening
include game reviews and news comedic
advice podcasts and Daily News roundups
what he eats for breakfast depends on
the day but his favorite morning meals
are pancakes and huevos rancheros no
matter what he's eating he washes it
down with a tall glass of orange juice
his nutrition needs aren't like those of
a human but it's important to start the
day with a tasty meal no matter what
it's the little things that make life
worth living while he eats his breakfast
he reads a newspaper brought to him by
the foundation staff each morning
according to his request the publication
varies but no matter what his favorite
section is arts and style or human
interest he always reads the whole thing
from front to back including the
obituaries and wedding announcements he
only gets one a day after all and he
knows it's important to appreciate
things to their fullest extent and take
nothing for granted 10 am now it's time
for scp-2660 Tuesday to really get going
he hops in the shower and listens to
another podcast as he warms up literally
he likes the water to be as hot as the
foundation will allow before they
complain about the utility bill after he
dries off he gets a hankering for a
little bit of gaming just as he starts
to settle into his gaming chair and look
through his library of video games a
member of Task Force Town nine knocks on
the door to his containment room hey you
busy not really something going on yeah
we're just keeping an eye on a couple
religious groups of Interest according
to the chatter on the forums and a few
of the leaders social media accounts
they might be planning something
disruptive you know lots of posts about
a day of great freedom and unleashing
the Lord of Madness upon the pathetic
World Cthulhu size must be a day that
ends in Hawaii sorry buddy the officer
shrugs not sure what else to say clearly
the two of them have spent their fair
share of days fending off mad cultists
you know the drill if anyone who's not
supposed to be here shows up start
sacrificing goats and such just let us
know hopefully it won't come to that we
should stop them before they get that
far hope so last time they got blood
everywhere and broke my copy of Resident
Evil 4. 12 p.m time flies when you're
having fun and when you're pacing back
and forth worried about cultists
breaking in to bother you with who knows
what before long it's 12 o'clock and
that means lunchtime when it comes to
lunch
scp-2662 has simple tastes he likes a
good old grilled cheese and tomato soup
a bean burrito or a steaming bowl of
ramen with that he's partial to a sugary
soda or sometimes lemonade he often
likes to tune into gaming streams on
Twitch especially obscure Indie titles
or if he's feeling like something a bit
more familiar Minecraft but on this
particular day he has a visitor
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
has swung by with his own lunch to have
a catch-up chat a huge fan of meeting
other friendly anomalies especially
those completely different from himself
scp-507 often stops by cthulhu's
containment room whenever he happens to
be in the same Dimension hey Squidward
how's it going
scp-2662 hasn't seen the show that this
particular nickname came from but he
enjoys being called a friendly name
instead of some manner of esoteric title
during this visit scp-5 007 shares
stories of his recent travels with
scp-2662 including his recent disturbing
brush with a smiling man and is much
more delightful time in a dimension
where he found himself on a beach where
the sand was made of popcorn and the sea
was made of Coca-Cola anywhere Cults
come by lately he asks after finishing
his story not a few weeks tentacles
crossed it stays that way but you know
my luck someone will probably be drawing
Arcane symbols on the walls and doing
weird chants in no time bummer 507
nodded sympathetically want to play
co-op for a bit I haven't had time in
forever sure even when it's a rare treat
it's always nice to spend time with a
friend doing something you both love
even if we can't relate much about
scp-2662's day-to-day life we can at
least relate to that it doesn't have to
be gaming either it can be painting
baking or even just watching a TV show
you love the activity doesn't matter
nearly as much as the company after all
1 30 PM after about an hour of game with
scp-507
scp-2662 gets an unwelcome Interruption
just when the two enter a new dungeon
ready to take on the bosses waiting
there right when
scp-2662s to be healed
scp-507 disappears from his seat popping
over to wherever his anomalous Dimension
hopping ability dragged him to next oh
goodbye he knows 507 can't hear him but
he wants to bid him farewell just the
same he turns to his computer and Boots
up a game he can play by himself he only
hopes his friend was sent somewhere safe
and that he'll come back sometime soon
2PM at 2 o'clock
scp-2662 gets yet another unwelcome
Interruption a loud boom rocks the room
as explosives detonate nearby breaking a
wall of the containment unit open while
the mobile task forces do their best to
subdue the Invaders responsible they are
all knocked out by a grenade filled with
an unidentifiable form of sleeping gas
with no one to turn them a group of
strange civilians in red robes come
pouring into
scp-2662's room oh great and powerful
Lord of Darkness we come to free you
from this infernal prison one man shouts
brandishing a candelabra filled with lit
black candles oh no thanks I'm good here
but we brought you an offering another
man steps forward tossing a bag of dried
bats onto 2662's bed hey oh man I sleep
there crows Cthulhu groans we have 13
more offerings and then the sacrificial
ritual can commence you just need to
come with us so it can begin the day of
great Freedom when you will Unleash Your
Thousand-Year reign of Madness upon the
land I'm not really into madness I'm
more into OverWatch
scp-2662 backs away from the supplicants
even as they come at him with more and
more grotesque offerings cow tongues
unidentifiable mushrooms one woman tries
to hand him a crying baby he refuses
each one but they are persistent is he
swatting away jars of pickled frogs a
woman begins drawing a circle around the
room and what he hopes is red paint but
fears is something else entirely
um thank you for all these gifts you
have proven yourself as loyal followers
I'm going to stay here though to uh
spread the madness from here you you can
all go home he tries to shoot them out
but they continue to press closer
thankfully his rescue finally shows up
task force Town 9 swoops in at this
point and begins knocking out and
administering amnestics to all of the
cultists they may not be able to cure
them of their mad devotion but they can
at least make sure the cult forgets the
location of the containment unit at
least for a little while they're able to
dispense with these particular Intruders
humanely but they may need to use lethal
Force for the next ones that's always a
possibility after the cultists have been
removed from the site some maintenance
staff are called in to repair the damage
to the wall where the explosives knocked
it in while they worked 2662 goes over
his newspaper one more time making sure
he didn't miss anything attention to
detail is an important skill to have
especially if one intends to get the
most out of their everyday life he finds
a few editorials he neglected to read
before and enjoys finishing up the
newspaper in its entirety 4pm after the
task force returns to their stations and
the maintenance crew has finished fixing
the wall
scp-2662 turns to one of his newest
Hobbies he attempted to hide this
Pursuit from the foundation at first but
they agreed to let him try it out as
long as he followed some safety
precautions so now at around 4 pm every
day
scp-2662 streams on his very own twitch
Channel he never uses identifying
information and keeps his camera turned
off the entire time plus the internet
sees his tentacle to face but he does
talk to the few viewers in his chat via
a microphone what's up it's squid boy 26
62 back to play some games for you guys
again hope you're all having a killer
day and thanks for tuning in today I'm
going to be checking out Apex Legends
for the very first time a lot of you
recommended this game to me so I'm
stoked to check it out as a small fan
Community watches
scp-2662 tries out the popular MMORPG
and plays his way through it for several
hours one person in the chat asks if he
has ever heard of the quote great
tentacled Beast of Legend but he makes
sure to block them before they give the
rest of the chat to any ideas he doesn't
want people to watch his streams because
he's some famous elder god or something
he wants to be liked for who he is 7pm
every gamer needs to break for some fuel
and
scp-2662 is no exception at around 7 he
wraps up his dream thanks all of his
viewers and subscribers and gets ready
to have some dinner he throws on another
podcast this time an actual play podcast
following a tabletop gaming campaign and
digs into his last meal of the day like
all this other meals it varies from day
to day but most of the time he goes with
his favorite pizza a big cheese pizza
delivered from a local pizza shop by a
delivery boy who has received more than
his fair share of amnestics and can
never remember why exactly this random
unmarked building seems so familiar
munching on his pizza and listening to
Tales of magic and Mayhem acted out by a
group of friends at a game table
scp-2662 can't help but feel just a
little Melancholy he's happy with what
he has of course but he dreams of a
normal life the kind of life where he
and his friends could play games
together or record a podcast where he
could share this pizza with someone else
but he might not ever have that and it's
something that he has to accept he can
still choose to appreciate what he has
rather than mourn what he doesn't after
he's finished eating and the episode is
finished it's back to the normal grind
at the computer he turns on the Sims for
a little while constructing the kind of
normal life he'd like to fantasize about
sometimes but then one of Sims burns
down the house while trying to make eggs
and he gives up on that particular
Endeavor to play some Minecraft 11 pm
Some Nights the excitement keeps
scp-2662 awake and playing his games
until the wee hours of the morning
tonight however he finds himself
exhausted from an unexpectedly
action-packed day courtesy of those
cultists he Powers down the game turns
on his final podcast of the day a guided
meditation to wind him down for sleep
and climbs into bed tomorrow he'll get
up and do it all again doing his best to
carve out a little bit of Peace in a
strange chaotic World maybe tomorrow
he'll just be left alone allowing to be
himself instead of what everyone expects
him to be he'll just have to stick it
out and see that's the beauty of life
after all tomorrow is always a new day
want to own an SCP of your own go to
scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise there are places in the
Multiverse that human beings were never
meant to find
worlds populated with swarms of crawling
spiders isolated dimensional prisons
were faceless corpses mimic the living
and Realms bathed in the purest Darkness
were a glimmer of Light May reveal more
than what a visitor might ever want to
see these places serve to remind us that
every one of us is before any other
essential quality of our collective
experience alone every human mind is an
isolated incident struggling to make
sense of every environment while hoping
to find common ground with the other
people in our lives we strive to
understand others and be understood but
sadly it is often the case that we must
interact with fellow human beings whose
motivations seem alien to us all too
frequently we are surrounded by people
we cannot relate to in situations we
have little control over and even if we
make attempts to articulate ourselves
there will always be an insurmountable
Gulf between the limits of our
experience and others as far as each of
us knows we are the only free willed
individuals in the cosmos and even the
nature of that Free Will is deeply in
question while many of us become
overwhelmed by these bigger questions
and are forced to confront our inherent
loneliness there is an instinct to turn
to unfeeling things for answers surely
the vast expanse of creation that made
us must have done so for a reason most
of who asked that question spend their
entire lives waiting for confirmation of
that reason they reach out for something
or somewhere that they are meant to be
it is only the vanishing rare few that
find it an unmistakable answer in an
unspeakable place a terrifying Vista of
Madness that all but screams you will
never belong
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
has found himself in places like these
more times than he is able to count he
has seen the spiders the room of corpses
that mimic human activity and has peered
through the darkness assisted by a
flashlight and seen only the smiling
face of a humanoid monster there are
dozens more frightening and unsettling
universes that scp-507 has encountered
and all known instances have been
archived in document
scp-507-3b any one of the innumerable
Horrors that this otherwise ordinary
human male has endured would send a
shiver down the spine of the best of us
but unfortunately this is little Comfort
to a CPE 507 facing down The Madness of
the abyss and returning intact starts to
become less triumphant when it is a
weekly sometimes daily occurrence the
dimension Hopper can barely have a
moment of Peace in this life as his
irregular shifts into different
realities occur without any warning and
all the research that the foundation has
done on scp-507 seems to indicate that
there will never be an end to these
trips into the infinite but no end does
not necessarily imply the lack of a
beginning the tragic existence of
scp-507 could not have started without a
cause and part of the foundation's goal
in containing
scp-507 is to discern an explanation for
the humanoid signature unstable mode of
inter-dimensional travel so far the
experiments have raised one burning
question after another with scp-507
himself having difficulty recounting
some of the stranger aspects of the
dimension he hops into and in a grander
sense what it might all mean but the
foundation has no choice but to listen
intently to scp-507 and take notes on
everything he says in regards to his
condition after all the phenomenon of
Leaping to other worlds primarily affect
the dimension Hopper himself and can
really only be understood through a
thorough understanding of the subject
over the course of many inner views with
scp-507 the research team has pieced
together what they believe might be the
definitive history of The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper from his native reality
to the flux of ever-changing hellscapes
that occupies his current days while it
is impossible to verify due to the
imperfect nature of memory and the
countless traumas suffered by a cp507
the foundation believes that this record
can be used as a case study for further
investigation into the Multiverse itself
on a less practical level the interviews
can help the foundation to improve
containment for scp-507 and make sure
that his existence is as lacking in
unnecessary suffering as possible we're
going back to the beginning to the
earliest dimensional hops that
scp-507 can remember in detail
considering the persistent nature of
scp-507's anomalous capabilities it was
hardly surprising for the foundation to
learn that the human did not have a
conventional childhood 507 has never
made any mention of identifiable
biological parents nor of any Grade
School Educational facility public or
private in the absence of these markers
of normalcy
scp-507 describes spending an
indeterminate amount of his formative
years in a Fantastical realm known as
limonora though it has apparently been
decades since scp-507 has hopped into
luminora he was able to describe the
dimension in great detail a grassy plane
of a run with red honeycomb standing
stones that seemed to sing with
thousands of beautiful voices as the
wind blew through them the Skies of
luminora were colored a velvety bluish
purple which never got any dimmer than a
commercial night light there were
shallow streams of spring water that
seemed to run in all directions
regardless of elevation there were also
dangers in limonore flocks of swooping
Birds which scp-507 described as having
the appearance of skinless vultures
these vultures would often attempt to
capture scp-507 and bring him to a
location known as the dawnwell as one
might expect 507 was never actually
apprehended by the creatures but insists
that these were more than ordinary Birds
of Prey vultures don't hunt for live
human children being scavengers after
all it has also been made clear that 507
was the only human of any sort in
lumenora this has led the researchers to
conclude that he most likely wasn't born
in that reality and had previously
hopped there from a dimension of origin
that remains inaccessible due to his
lack of memories during infancy the
dimension Hopper claims that his best
friend finnicker always protected him
from these avian threats finnicker was
another creature native to limonora who
resembled an anomalous crustacean the
size of a large dog covered in what
scp-507 believed to be a coat of tufted
brown fur when fending off the vultures
vinegar carried a heavy cudgel in one of
his claws the blunt instrument was said
to be carved from the same material as
the musical Standing Stones additionally
507 has remarked that the inside of
vinegar shell was mostly Hollow and
could be used as a shelter and resting
place for the young Dimension Hopper as
long as he had the continued friendship
of the creature many researchers who
have taken statements from scp-507
regarding the menorah have reflexively
come to view the unconfirmed dimension
and 507's experiences therein as the
product of a wild imagination made more
Vivid due to a traumatic upbringing on
the other hand
scp-507 insists that limonora is not a
psychological coping mechanism and is in
fact just as real as all the other
dimensions he has hopped into it is
difficult to dismiss his account
entirely as no matter how many times
scp-507 is asked about lemonor and how
far apart the interviews are the details
of the account never seem to deviate
from what had previously been
established during his time in limonora
which may have spanned more than a year
507 has stated that he was the happiest
that he had ever been whenever he wasn't
avoiding the vultures of The Well of
dawn 507 passed Time by listening to the
music from The Standing Stones surfing
the erratic currents of the shallow
streams and learning rudimentary carving
techniques with finnicker in some ways
luminora was a paradise for a child
there was no homework or chores and
whenever it was safe he could play
outside as much as he wanted it wasn't
until one terrible night that everything
about his isolated existence changed for
the worst while falling asleep inside
feniker's shell
scp-507 experienced a random dimensional
shift to a deep and forbidding Force
at first he thought this new reality was
a dream as it was abnormally dark and
Misty nothing like lemonora then he saw
them the so-called mammal men
scp-507 remembered their chattering
teeth long and orange like beaver's
teeth as well as the leathery pale skin
that covered their misshapen bodies the
mammal men roared and hissed making
unnatural noises as they chewed into the
trees the sound of it all was very
distressing for young
scp-507 who began to flee from the
strange humanoids into the nearby bushes
he cried out for finnicker hoping that
his friend would arrive and protect him
but it didn't happen and try as he might
it seemed as though he couldn't wake up
from this nightmare it wasn't a
nightmare at all in fact but a true
dimensional shift from which there could
be no easy return terrified for reasons
Beyond his comprehension the young
dimensional Hopper continued to cry out
for his only friend the was a sudden
crack and allowed whoosh as one of the
great trees of the forest came toppling
down in his Direction
scp-507 braced himself for the
inevitable impact but it never came he
was in what appeared to be a city now
and it was the middle of the day crowds
of human beings surrounded him and the
sounds of automobiles and phone calls
drowned his mind in the cacophony it was
a total sensory overload compared to
limonora and being exposed to it after
having such a harrowing experience in
the forest Dimension caused scp-507 to
break down into tears he continued to
weep and call out for finnicker but his
crustacean friend was several Worlds
Away now when the authorities eventually
arrived given a call about a lost child
scp-507 was brought to the nearby police
station the officers tried to ask
scp-507 questions presumably about where
his parents were or where his home was
but 507 recalls being unable to
understand the language they were
speaking and thus there was no hope of
communication the adults seemed equally
frustrated and tried speaking to the
child in a number of different languages
eventually when no parent or Guardian
appeared to claim the child it was
determined that scp-507 would be placed
in foster care from their scp-507 was
given to a family that soon became his
legal Guardians he was homeschooled on
many of the basic subjects of Science
and Math and learned the English
language through constant tutoring while
his new parents and siblings were
willing to entertain his stories of
limonora and finnicker they believed it
was little more than the fantasy of an
imaginary friend throughout the rest of
his youth
scp-507 experienced no unusual Dimension
hopping and began to live a relatively
normal and unremarkable life at a
certain point he even began to believe
that limonora never existed none of the
other children he knew had ever
experienced something like it the fact
that they would constantly remind him of
in their ruthless teasing even so
scp-507 entered his teen years as a
shockingly normal individual given the
circumstances while the foundation has
never been able to verify the names and
identities of his foster family members
mostly because scp-507 has been
reluctant to divulge any related
information his seeming loyalty to
keeping the people who raised him
anonymous is proof enough that this
chapter of his life was not fabricated
according to scp-507's testimony the
involuntary shifting began to reoccur
not long after he had gone through
puberty the sudden disappearance is
worried his family and many times they
believed that he had attempted to run
away from home this also had an impact
on his social and educational
development as maintaining both
friendships and good grades in high
school were difficult when he could
disappear for days and weeks at a time
the vast majority of these dimensional
leaps are uneventful Beyond The Strain
they put on
scp-507's efforts at a normal life but
one in particular has left a lasting
impact on 507 it was during a Halloween
block party in his senior year when
scp-507 shifted away during an attempt
to refill his punch he blinked in shock
to find himself in limonora once more
but it was not as he had left it the sky
was a deep shade of maroon and cracked
like a glass surface from there these
cracks spilled sand like rain onto the
now desolate Plains and dried up Rivers
The Standing Stones were mostly broken
and there was no wind to conduct them
into their song the teenage 507 wandered
around this ruined limonora in disbelief
the Fantastical place he remembered had
been real for his entire life but now it
was dead if that wasn't traumatizing
enough nothing could prepare him for
what awaited at The Well of dawn near
the strange pit of emanated sunlight was
the rotted sunbleached shell of a
massive station vinegar 507 barely had
any time to take in the sight of his
long-lost friend before he was returned
to the roof of the Halloween party that
was the last time he ever saw the world
of lemonorah but it was far far from the
most horrific sites that the Multiverse
would have to offer want to own an SCP
of your own go to scpswag.com for
premium anomalous merchandise uh what
about this one when SCP researcher
called to the other you've got to be
kidding his colleague scoffed
interpreting the suggestion as little
more than a joke that thing's a piece of
junk she tapped a knuckle against the
glass case catching the attention of the
tiny figure inside Who Dares exclaimed
the tinny monotone voice Release Me From
This irksome confinement so that I might
bring about your final undoing Vermin
for I Am doombah 2000 the ultimate
bringer of Destruction both researchers
laughed at the small automaton inside
the glass they had come to a CP item
Gallery 27 in search of non-organic
anomalies to gather for testing but
judging by their reactions it seemed
that scp-1370 wasn't going to make the
cut the Cobble together robot was widely
considered to be a harmless clumsy
little Oddity rather than any kind of
threat but that didn't stop
scp-1370 from challenging any and all
things around it to a battle to the
death battles it always lost now this
thing is junk the second researcher
remarked flicking her finger at the
glass again in an attempt to startle the
robot it is not organic though the other
pointed out observing that scp-1370 had
been constructed out of various recycled
Parts its head was a defunct and
non-operational voltmeter soldered
awkwardly onto a weak neck joint its
arms were wrenches and it had been
configured in such a way that gave the
robot a top-heavy impractical design
inorganic yes but worth our time
definitely not come on we'll find
something else to test in scp-914 as the
pair of researchers turn their backs on
scp-1370 it began to squawk at them
again through the speaker embedded in
its chest you dare walk away from me you
have incurred the wrath of Robo Lord the
destructor and will soon be reduced to
Adams by my hand the tiny junk robot
charged towards the two Foundation
personnel only to slam front first into
the glass of the display case it was
kept contained in the force of the
impact combined with scp-1370s imbalance
design caused it to topple over and land
on its back leaving a huge crack in the
glass ah great one of the researchers
side rolling her eyes we're gonna have
to report that
scp-1370s damaged its case again come on
let's go and get someone to replace that
glass you think we should just leave it
here unsupervised in a damaged case the
other asked look at the thing it's
hardly competent enough to escape the
fellow researcher replied as the tiny
robots struggled to get self back
upright I'm sure it'll be fine for a few
minutes little did the pair of
researchers realize as they left item
Gallery 27 that scp-1370 had been
listening to their conversation picking
up on a few details while the anomalous
automaton often displayed a low level of
intelligence and awareness of its
surroundings it was still self-aware and
on top of that harbored a hatred for all
things it believed to be living although
it could be easily tricked and lacked
any kind of real fighting ability but it
had picked up on something the
researchers had mentioned an
scp-914 perhaps through its own limited
intelligence or some kind of other
anomalous awareness the tiny robot
detected this to mean another machine
and so standing back up it struck the
glass of its display case again
shattering one side completely it hopped
down to the ground tumbling over thanks
to its lack of balance only to
eventually stand back up and start
making its way through the facility
being only a meter tall made it easy for
scp-1370 otherwise known as pesterbot to
sneak through the corridors of the
foundation site undetected it eventually
arrived at a room housing a large mass
of gears and Gyros a machine filled with
Clockwork components that seemed to pull
the little robot further in as it drew
closer and closer to what the
researchers had spoken of
scp-914 the Clockworks a device that
could be used to refine any object
placed inside it depending on the
setting items could be transformed
destroyed or vastly improved using the
Clockworks rough setting disintegrated
any test subject while coarse dismantled
it to its base components one to one
replaced any item with an almost
identical copy then the fine setting
would cause scp-914 to improve any item
and very fine could refine an object to
an even greater degree usually by
granting its anomalous properties
testing of all biological matter within
scp-914 was strictly prohibited but
pesterbot well he was made of metal
sneaking into the room where the
Clockworks was located
scp-1370 immediately caught sight of
another Foundation researcher who had
been busy overseeing tests using the
very fine setting of scp-914 instantly
the agitated Little Robot made a beeline
for the researcher swiping at her ankles
with its wrench hands die die a
intrigued cower before the might of my
claws none can stand before the
Relentless destruction brought forth by
shivatron to spoiler of Mirth referring
to itself with one of its many elaborate
self-appointed titles caught by surprise
that the tiny robot the researcher
turned and screamed in Surprise
instinctively she swung her leg back and
brought it Forward delivering a swift
kick to scp-1370 that sent its metal
body hurtling through the air right into
the Clockworks pesterbot landed inside
the input Booth the enormous collection
of clockwork components whirring and
heaving as they sprung to life the
researcher hadn't even realized what was
happening she'd been addressing how much
her foot hurt after kicking the small
metal robot by the time she looked up
scp-914 had already fully activated with
scp-1370 inside in horror she sounded
the alarm to summon security with no
idea what the very fine setting would do
to improve pester a team of guards filed
into the room drawing their weapons and
training them on the output Booth of the
Clockworks while they normally would
have nothing to fear from
scp-1370 given its inability to ever win
in a fight that it started even when
fighting a potted plant that had been
affixed with a speaker the tiny robot
had been bested but the clockwork's
refinement process meant that what would
be stepping out of the machine wouldn't
be the pesterbot the foundation was
familiar with sure enough the heavy foot
that came stomping down on the facility
floor was a far cry from the flimsy
metal limbs
scp-1370 had previously had out of the
Clockworks emerged a hulking robotic
form not just bigger and bulkier than
the meter tall clumsy assembled
pesterbot but a huge Sleek machine built
for Bear it was more humanoid but stood
at nearly seven feet tall the weight and
balance issues that had plagued the
previous design were seemingly gone as
despite its increased size this new and
improved model of scp-1370 seemed to
move fluidly with smooth electronic
motions the robot turned and assessed
its surroundings scanning the group of
foundation security that had amassed
outside
scp-914 its first new targets as the
machine stepped towards them the
security Commander gave the word and the
guards opened fire a hail of gunfire
rang out deafening shots ringing in the
security officer's years as bullets spat
out of their weapons towards the newly
refined pesterbot by the time each of
them had emptied their magazines and the
smoke cleared they realized to their
Terror that the robot was now
bulletproof you have engaged in an act
of violence against Doom Master 1370
master of all doom it announced in a new
voice one far deeper and more imposing
than its previous tinny Candor now it
was a modulated electronic sound far
befitting its new look prepare to face
consequences
retaliating with that the robot leaped
into battle with all the grace and
ferocity of a wild cat the nearest
security guard barely had a chance to
reload his weapon raising his hands in a
weak attempt to add a block before the
strike from a metallic fist knocked the
wind out of him moving with balletic
speed and precision pesterbot swiped and
shot at the guard each hit connecting
painfully with one of the man's vital
pressure points like it was a highly
trained hand-to-hand fighter when the
officer collapsed unable to move save
for letting out screams of excruciating
pain the robot turned to face its
remaining targets freeze one of the
foundation's security yelled raising his
pistol was shaking hands zipping
forwards scp-1370 grabbed the gun and
wrenched it from the man's fingers
tearing the weapon apart like it was
made of cardboard ripping the man by his
SCP Foundation uniform it launched him
directly upwards sending his body
crashing through the ceiling leaving a
human-shaped hole above chunks of
building materials rained down on the
robot including wiring and internal
lengths of cable that ran through the
walls and ceiling that were now exposed
as the security team retreated
scp-1370 curiously reached up and
gripped one of the electric cables
wrenching it out of the ceiling to
examine it closer causing Sparks to
shower pesterbot's new Sleek metallic
skin seemed to react to the metal in the
wiring drawing out the cop offer that
channeled electricity throughout the
foundation facility it was more than a
force of magnetism it was something else
ideas
scp-1370 was learning adapting and most
frightening of all coming up with new
ways to complete its purpose marching up
to the nearest wall it pulled back in
metal Fist and sent it slamming through
paintwork and plaster to draw out the
metal running through the building
outside in the corridor the lights died
in fact the entire facility lost its
power and plunged Into Darkness until
the backup emergency lights activated
filling the foundation's corridors with
low-level blood red light more security
officers had mobilized outside of the
Clockworks room expecting at any moment
that the refined version of the
previously harmless pesterbot would soon
appear sure enough it did and the red
lighting was soon added to by yet
another hail of frightening gunfire but
now it seemed
scp-1370 had learned how to shoot back
an arc of lightning Zapped through the
corridor electrifying every guard it
touched and reducing them to little more
than a smoldering husk a second one
followed striking one guard with a bolt
of blue electricity that then leaped
from his body to the officer standing
next to him who had been close enough to
touch his Fallen comrade and it was of
course wearing plenty of conductive
metal the wiring in the walls the
electricity
scp-1370 had learned how to weaponize it
and that wasn't all as the robot stepped
out of the room it had pulled various
other metalwork from the fabric of the
building around it into its form adding
to its body in new and gruesome ways its
shoulders now had additional armor long
poles of rebar now extended out of its
robotic forearms to act as crude
rudimentary impaling weapons it had
gotten even taller and all forged out of
metal it harvested from its surroundings
scp-1370 hadn't just been made a better
fighter it had given something else by
scp-914 intelligence the capacity for it
to learn and perpetually adapt itself
and it wouldn't stop it would keep
improving itself to enact its original
purpose to fight anything and everything
around it a Slaughter ensue everything
the SCP Foundation threw at this new
version of the pesterbot only gave it
more weapons and more offensive
capabilities to add to its growing
Arsenal the rebar weapons and its arms
were replaced with Sleek sharp blades
even bullets fired at it seemed to be
absorbed into its mass allowing it to
keep growing
scp-1370 was Unstoppable obliterating
everyone that came to desperately try to
contain it and as it bested every
opponent left them decimated and
defeated something new happened to the
robot it couldn't feel emotions just
like with any automaton it lacked the
level of human cognition and complexity
to respond to things with feel
but as it killed more and more
Foundation staff left and right
annihilating everything in its path
scp-1370 experience something not an
emotion but whatever the closest robotic
equivalent to Pure unbridled happiness
was satisfaction of the machine now able
to complete the function it was
originally built for yet had failed that
for so long getting bigger and bigger
adapting and adding more machines to
itself eventually
scp-1370 was a hulking Behemoth cars and
their combustion engines all became part
of the robotic giant every new piece of
technology it encountered becoming a
deadly weapon and as pesterbot started
to Tower over buildings a huge scale
robotic threat the foundation had no
choice it was time to deploy another big
bad bot to cut
scp-1370 back down to size it was time
to send in the dragon slayer now go
check out what if scp-096 was put inside
scp-914 where the shy guys were fined
into well you'll have to click and see
and scp-914 what did you put in it to
see what happened when we opened up the
Clockworks to you the fans